[Musique]
Régisre le somier. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Alors, je m'appelle Régis le Somier. Je
suis né le 28 octobre 1968 à Toulon. Euh
je dirais presque par hasard puisque je
suis d'origine bretonne et en fait quand
je dis le hasard, c'était le hasard des
affectations de mon père qui était
sous-marin donc on allait un peu dans
tous les ports et voilà et je suis né à
Toulon. Euh cette enfance particulière
de de fils de sous-marin ça m'a a été
quand même quelque chose qui d'assez
structurant dans ma vie. Euh parce que
euh bah d'abord, j'étais avec un père
qui était euh officier donc officier de
marine très traditionnel, très euh
c'était pas un communiquant euh et on
avait
un t
c'était un t et il y a eu beaucoup de
choses que j'ai pas pu lui dire ou des
conversations que j'ai pas eu mais en
tout cas sa vie et sa carrière m'ont
m'ont profondément façonné je pense. Je
pense que si j'ai voulu devenir
reporter, c'est aussi à cause de ça.
Je voyais les contraintes auxquelles
étaient assujetti mon père en tant que
officier et participant à un effort. Il
a travaillé notamment sur les les SNLE,
donc sur les sous-marins nucléaires. Il
partait 75 jours sous l'eau et et puis
nous on l'attendait et on essayait de
comprendre un peu cette ce métier
particulier. Et puis un jour, je me en y
réfléchissant, je me je me disais mais
en fait cette enfance, il y avait
l'équipage et puis notamment quand on
quand mon père arrivé à l'île longue,
c'est la base des des SNLE à côté de
Brest, euh on était complètement en
fait, on faisait partie de l'équipage
d'une certaine façon. On nous amenait,
je me souviens de des comment notamment
des arbres de Noël où on partait de
Brest en bateau. On arrivait à l'î
longue, on longeait des corridors avec
des barbelets de de droite et de gauche.
Il y avait des chiens, il y avait des
Fumako à l'époque, donc des fusillers
marins commando et qui qui surveillaient
la base. Puis on nous mettait dans un
dans un comment dans un hangar, il y
avait un marin qui s'habillait en père
Noël, prenait nos cadeaux et puis on
repartait. qui avait un petit côté un
peu étrange et beaucoup de choses que
j'ai pas compris euh quand j'étais quand
j'étais petit, quoi. Voilà. Et euh et ce
père a été a eu quand même pour moi
voilà cette euh cette idée de d'aller
euh euh je me suis toujours interrogé
sur le fait de se mettre dans un sorte
d'étui à cigar comme ça et de passer des
mois sous l'eau. Euh il y avait euh
c'était la guerre froide. Euh il me
racontait de façon très succinte parce
qu'il était complètement tenu au secret.
Euh ce qu'il pouvait me raconter, il me
parlait du du chalutier russe euh qui
escortait le sous-marin dès qu'il
sortait du goulet de Brest. Donc il y
avait toujours cette ambiance vraiment
cette ambiance de guerre froide. C'était
le début des années 80. Euh voilà ça a
comment marqué ma jeunesse. Quand mon
père revenait, on nous faisait louper la
classe par exemple pour aller
immédiatement à la montagne où on
retrouvait
les gens de l'équipage en fait. Et euh
c'était un milieu clos. Euh on ne
fréquentait quasiment que les fils et
les filles de sous-marins. On voyait
même pas de gens de la marine de surface
notamment à l'époque nucléaire. Il était
dans dans les dans les SNLE. Et euh
voilà, c'était c'est ça a été une
enfance heureuse mais un peu étrange et
je dirais que ça m'a donné pas mal le
goût de l'aventure quand même euh en
m'imaginant au départ quand j'étais
jeune ce que mon père la vie que pouvait
mener mon père quand il était à l'époque
c'était les sous-marins, les sous le
pôle nord. Euh il il jouait au chat et à
la souris avec les autres marines. Euh
et il y avait donc cette espèce de de
d'interrogation permanente. Il me disait
jamais exactement où il allait. Euh il
m'a raconté un peu plus tard, mais il y
a toujours eu des parts euh de nom dit,
des parts de de secret euh chez ce père
et et beaucoup de choses que finalement
j'ai jamais pu lui dire ni voilà. Donc
euh je lui ai rendu hommage dans un
livre mais euh mais ça ça a été voilà ça
m'a mis un peu sur les fonds bâtism et
ça m'a donné aussi l'idée que un jour
moi aussi je pourrais aller voyager mais
certainement pas dans un sous-marin
certainement pas au fond des mers euh
mais plutôt
pour quelle motivation ?
Pour quelle motivation ?
La défense de la patrie.
Je pense que c'était ça. Il y avait
aussi l'idée de de l'ascenseur social
qui était très puissant chez lui qui
avait été le cas chez mon grand-père.
Nous, on vient de Bretagne de milieux
très modestes et ruraux. Et euh c'est
quoi le nom du village ?
On vient de Plintrig àavou. Donc euh je
pense que vous ne connaissez pas
par les Breton
euh Tamic Bia. Et euh j'ai donc mon
si ces origines là ont fait que dans la
famille Oui, il y a eu il y a eu mes
deux grands-pères comme ça qui ont qui
ont profité de de je sais pas si on peut
l'appeler l'ascenseur républicain,
c'est-à-dire cette capacité justement de
de
comment de sortir de la ferme et puis de
finir euh ingénieur en chef sur un
sous-marin. Ça a été euh voilà, c'était
ça qu'il le motivait. Alors bien sûr, il
y avait la notion de patrie, il y avait
la notion de dévotion, il y avait une
certaine droiture euh que je vais pas
dire que j'ai épousé toujours cette
cette certaine droiture. J'ai eu une
adolescence tumueuse comme pas mal
d'ados. Euh je me suis rebellé contre
mes parents bien sûr, mais euh mais en
tout cas cette cette Oui, il y avait
dans ces générations là euh un sens du
sacrifice quand même assez assez
puissant euh qui a toujours enfin ça a
toujours été une des caractéristiques
des Bretons, hein. Il y a un côté
rebelle et puis un côté très euh très
obéissant, très discipliné, très
Un marin un marin reste toujours libre.
Un marin un marin reste libre. Oui. Euh
surtout sur son sur son est
mais oui. Et vous ne croyez pas si bien
dire quand euh plus tard j'ai fait des
un sujet à bord d'un sous-marin d'un
SNLE et je discutais avec le
Vous avez fait un sujet parce que vous
êtes quand même reporteur de guerre. Je
vous laisse terminer votre présentation
ou je l'ai fini ?
Bah finissez là. Mais non mais oui pour
clôturer tout ça. Oui, je suis reporter
je suis reporter de guerre. Euh c'est
euh
voilà, j'ai j'ai poursuivi d'une
certaine façon, si on peut le lier à
l'enfance, cette euh cette idée de de
partir et cette idée de larguer les
amars euh et puis d'aller découvrir le
monde et d'aller me confronter au monde
aussi. Je pense que ça a été toujours ça
qui m'a motivé et l'autre motivation
essentielle pour laquelle j'ai fait ce
métier, c'est d'accompagner l'histoire.
Alors, c'est pareil, c'est pognon.
Non, pas du tout. Non. Si j'avais voulu
faire ce métier pour le pognon, j'aurais
choisi autre chose. En plus, à l'époque
où je l'ai commencé, il y avait des gens
qui faisaient des des belles carrières
dans la publicité ou dans d'autres même
dans les médias, il y avait encore
belle carrière dans la publicité quand
même.
C'est c'est quand même magnifique.
Non mais si c'était là où il y avait de
l'argent, c'était pas ça faire une belle
car.
Non mais vous me demandez vous me
demandez si je l'ai fait pour de
l'argent. Non, évidemment,
je l'ai fait un peu par hasard aussi
parce que
quand j'ai j'ai fait Science Po l'IP de
Lyon, il fallait que je trouve un
comment il fallait que je trouve un
stage en entreprise entre ma 2e et ma 3e
année. Et à l'époque, je savais pas du
tout quoi faire dans la vie, hein. J'ai
fait Science Po même, j'avais 23 ans.
J'ai pas fait en en première année, j'ai
fait en admission parallèle. J'avais
déjà une licence de d'histoire et euh et
quand je quand il a fallu trouver euh ce
stage, je me suis souvenu que j'avais un
copain dont dont un des pères était
rédacteur en chef à Paris Match en
l'occurrence Patrick Ma et euh et je lui
ai demandé, je ne connaissais pas
Patrick Ma, je lui ai demandé est-ce que
tu peux avoir un stage ? J'ai besoin de
Mais le stage, je suis arrivé au stage à
Paris match avec l'idée de faire un
stage en entreprise, c'est-à-dire le
l'idée de rendre un rapport avec des
chiffres, comment ça fonctionne dans
cette dans cette voilà, j'ai j'ai je ne
j'avais pas du tout l'idée de d'en faire
ma carrière. Et puis quand je suis
arrivé à Paris Match, c'était en 94,
tout à coup, j'ai vu euh les grands
reporters qui revenaient à l'époque,
c'était les Balcons, c'était la Tchenie
et qui a raconté leur leurs histoires,
les petites histoires dans dans c'est
pas forcément des choses qu'ils avaient
écrit dans leur leur reportage, mais la
façon dont ils s'en étaient tiré d'une
d'un mauvais mauvaise passe ou quand ils
avaient réussi à sortir de telle ou
telle ville, des situations que je
connaîtrai plus tard. euh la sortie de
Grosen par exemple ou des euh des des
choses voilà dans des dans des dans des
dans des atmosphères de combat très
intense. Euh et tout à coup là, je me
suis dit c'est ça que je veux faire. Je
me suis dit euh voilà, je vais je vais
m'accrocher parce que ça a pas été
simple. Euh il a fallu jouer des coudes,
il a fallu être euh
naviguer
dans les eaux du journalisme parisien
aussi. Pourquoi
? C'est un milieu qui est putride, c'est
ça ?
C'est pas un milieu. Non, au contraire,
on en avait des des chevaliers là.
C'était pas euh Non, simplement il faut
faire ses armes. Et un match quand on
faisait un coup, c'estàdire quand on
ramenait une bonne histoire pendant une
semaine, ah on était le on était le roi
et puis la semaine suivante euh c'était
fini. Il fallait sans cesse sans cesse
remettre euh le le métier sur sur
l'ouvrage et sans cesse se remettre en
question. Donc c'était et moi je j'ai dû
rester euh je sais pas pigiste pendant
euh euh 6 7 ans. Euh donc c'était
c'était pas simple. Euh vous dites
atmosphère putride ? Non pas pas
vraiment. Ça faisait plutôt qu'à
l'époque c'était c'était propre encore.
Bah euh disons qu'il y avait un journal
qui marchait, qui était enfin qui marche
toujours hein. reste un des fleurons de
la presse française mais euh disons
qu'il y avait il y avait des moyens, il
y avait et puis il y avait on envoyait
des gens dès qu'il y avait un quelque
chose qui se passait quelque part, cette
capacité à immédiatement répondre,
partir tout presque ce que ce que je
connaîtrai plus tard, c'estàdire l'idée
de faire son sac ou l'idée de de dire on
va quand même garder le sac un peu un
peu plein parce que on risque de partir
quoi. on était toujours sur cette
toujours sur la brèche en fait et c'est
ça qui m'intéressait c'était vraiment de
de dès l'époque, je me souviens de
m'être fait cette réflexion là.
Après à match, on fait tout. Ça m'est
arrivé même de couvrir le festival de
Cann, de faire des des des incursions
dans dans des sujets entre guillemets
people ou des choses incursion au
festival de cann, c'est magnifique.
Oui mais oui oui oui, je l'ai fait, je c
c'est une jungle comme une autre hein.
Oui, c'est pareil hein. C'est un terrain
de guerre aussi hein. Mais non,
beaucoup de drogués aussi.
Il y a beaucoup de drogués. Il y a
beaucoup de Mais oui, j'ai fait je l'ai
fait quelques années, ça a été mais
voilà, je je considérais ça comme des
expériences. Je je ne considère pas non
plus la guerre comme un absolu. Euh ce
n'est pas parce que il y a la guerre
quelque part que c'est forcément euh
incroyablement intéressant. Incroyable
Il y a d'autres sujets. Euh il y a aussi
les conséquences de la guerre. Il y a
aussi les sujets
pas du genre le comment il s'appelle le
présentateur de télé sur France 2 là
quand il a vu un avion tomber sur la
tour du 11 septembre la tour du Waltr
Trad Center, il a fait "Oh c'est
génial."
Ouais.
Vous voyez qui je veux dire ? Je vois
pas qui vous voulez dire mais bon
un petit qui parle beaucoup qui pour pas
grand-chose. Non, vous voyez pas qui je
veux dire ?
Non, pas du tout. Non,
avec une mèche.
Ouais, c'est pas de la mèche, c'est un
autre.
D'accord.
Qui est petit là, vous voyez pas ?
Non, je vois pas.
Non. Qui aime bien avoir un scooter pas
en doré ? Alors euh non, je vois pas qui
c'est mais mais en attendant euh euh
face aux événements, parfois on a des
réactions impulsives et euh je pense que
s'il a dit c'est génial,
ça c'est la corporation ça. Ça c'est la
corporation qui parle. Je veux pas le
défendre parce que je sais que parfois
quand on a quelque chose
d'extraordinaire qui arrive devant nous,
bah on réagit comme des hommes. On n'est
pas complètement de bois. Une petite
réaction comme un trader voyant la
plusvalue.
Ouais.
Là, on voyait à peu près ce l'appel du
sang.
Ouais. Ouais. Alors ça c'est c'est
souvent des gens qui ont pas pratiqué
ces terrainsl qui ont souvent ce genre
de résumer trivialement votre
présentation succinte.
Vous êtes reporteur de guerre, vous êtes
vous avez commencé en tant que pigiste à
Paris match sur le coup d'un piston d'un
pote et vous avez si je résume très
chose et vous avez terminé
directeur adjoint de la rédaction de
Paris Match.
Tout à fait.
Et là vous êtes reporter grand reporter
à RT France.
Tout à fait.
On peut commencer l'interview ?
Oui, allons-y.
Non,
c'était très intéressant votre petite
histoire. On comprend un peu mieux. On a
on a beaucoup de de copains reporters de
guerre, des envoyés sur le terrain et
que ce soit différentes nationalités en
différentes langues, en différents pays.
Et notre premier reporteur de guerre
pote, il a commencé à Morrovia.
Ça vous fait penser quoi à Morovia ?
Bah, Morvia, ça c'est j'y suis jamais
allé mais euh ça me fait penser à la
photo la plus célèbre euh de mon ami
photographe Chrisondros
euh avec qui j'ai couvert l'Irak et qui
j'ai couvert l'Afghanistan et plein
d'autres choses aux États-Unis, des
ouragans et voilà tout un tas de de
sujets et qui a été tué en Libye en 2011
et
à son âme
voilà et qui a fait cette photo
extraordinaire à Mrovia où on voit un
combattant de Charles Taylor torenu qui
vient d'aller balancer son RPG et il
revient sur le pont et heureux d'avoir
envoyé son missile, il saute en l'air,
il a ces dreadlock qui sont voilà et
c'est la photo la plus connue de de
Chris et c'est la photo sur chaque
guerre vous savez il y a il y a une
photo bien sûr moi j'ai vécu avec ça 25
ans avec à Paris image directeur adjoint
de la rédaction la donne photographique
est fondamentale pour moi le le
le l'approche d'une histoire par la
photo est absolument essentielle. le
texte. Je suis je suis je suis du texte
moi, mais j'ai accompagné les
photographes, j'en accompagne toujours
et et c'est fondamental parce que c'est
c'est c'était le le le l'approche match,
c'est-à-dire la l'approche humaine,
souvent la la petite histoire dans la
grande, c'est-à-dire on va raconter euh
l'histoire d'un type ou d'un groupe de
personnes euh qui vont symboliser d'une
certaine façon l'actualité qui est en
cours et et l'incarnation est très
importante et l'incarnation à travers la
le la photo, elle peut être magistrale.
Donc j'ai j'ai eu cette chance inouie de
côtoyer des gens comme Chrisandros,
comme Noël Kidu, comme Véronique de
Vigri, comme Alvaro Canovas
qui avait que de les accompagner sur le
terrain et de travailler avec eux.
Dire qu'est-ce que ça veut dire de les
accompagner sur le terrain ? C'est en
physique ou les accompagner ? C'est
votre rédaction qui souscrit le contrat
pour son négociateur s'il se fait toper.
C'est quoi ? C'est c'est vous qui
fournissez les enveloppes de cash pour
vos fixeurs sur place. une légende
urbaine chez les reporteurs de guerre
qui dit match ils arrivent sur le
terrain, ils ont pas de ficur de fixeur,
ils ont que des enveloppes de cash. Donc
ils peuvent prendre 15 fixeurs tout de
suite.
Alors c'est bien c'est bien rodé parce
que comme ça quand ils se déplacent, ils
sortent de leur hôtel tout de suite ils
peuvent faire des belles photos.
Non
c'est une légende. C'est pas une
légende.
Je pense que c'est c'est une caricature.
Vous savez il y a tout plein plein de
choses qui traînent autour de match,
plein de de fantasmes
autour de ce journal. On peut en parler
très bien. Non, bien souvent on arrive,
on a du cash comme tout le monde hein.
C'est c'est des reportages. Non non,
c'est pas comme tout le monde.
Non mais si si on dit paris match, paris
match c'est le seul avoir du cash. Mais
quand vous êtes Non mais quand vous êtes
dans un pays où il y a pas de carte
bleue, vous êtes bien obligé d'avoir du
cash. L'histoire de la carte bleue,
c'est pas mal.
Non mais si c'est vrai, mais
quand vous allez en Syrie par exemple,
vous pouvez avoir utiliser votre carte
bleue au Liban. Vous pouvez pas vot
utiliser votre carte bleue en Syrie.
Ça dépend. Au Liban, vous pouvez
utiliser votre carte bleue de votre
carte bleue mais que pour tirer de la
monnaie de singe.
Oui, aujourd'hui je malheureusement le
Liban est tellement dans un une impasse
est tellement devenu euh un pays euh
bord du gouffre que je pense que oui,
effectivement c'est ça devient plus
compliqué. Mais euh voilà,
combien par exemple Hm hm
quand vous envoyez un reporter de guerre
euh que ce soit en Afghanistan, que ce
soit en Syrie, en Libye et cette longue
liste de pays en train de se
déstabiliser, vous lui donnez combien en
cash ? Bah ça ça va dépendre de la
mission, ça va dépendre de de l'endroit
où on va euh ça va dépendre aussi euh du
temps. Non non mais attention parce que
si vous voulez vous ravitailler en
semaines Siri 2 semaines
2 semaines
from scratch
mais je dirais 5000 € 6000 € ouais voilà
en sachant que il va falloir payer le
chauffeur donc il va falloir payer le
fixeur il va falloir aussi payer les
hôtels et dans les pays où il y a pas de
carte bleue les hôtels ils se payent en
en dollars en plus parfois ils acceptent
les euros mais pas partout j'ai connu
connu une époque en Afghanistan où
c'était uniquement les dollars.
Maintenant, on peut y aller avec des
euros. Mais ça c'est des choses
auxquelles vous devez penser avant de
partir. Voilà, il y a il y a tout un
mais c'est pas des sommes et on n'est
pas avec des lièes de billets à les
distribuer à tout le monde comme cette
légende qui est propagée par je ne sais
qui. Mais en tout cas, c'est pas du tout
comme ça que ça se passe. Moi, j'ai vu
parfois des des des moments où on a plus
de cash. Il y a pas de Western Union,
donc on peut pas
comment se faire ravitailler d'une
certaine façon. coin.
Ouais, mais je crois que ça marche moins
sur les champs de bataille. Je suis pas
sûr que voilà. Et non mais mais en tout
cas en tout cas ce que je veux dire
c'est que cette ce fantasme de l'argent
et de Paris match pour le grand
reportage c'est vraiment de la légende
urbaine quoi. C'est on n pas les
meilleures photos parce qu'on a de
l'argent, on a les meilleures photos
parce que d'abord on a des très bons
photographes et ensuite parce que bah
c'est la démerde quoi. C'est on a des
voilà quand on est sur place c'est
l'idée c'est on n'est pas plus
intelligent que les autres mais d'abord
il parfois les autres sont meilleurs que
nous. Euh et parfois les autres ont des
meilleures photos que nous. Euh mais en
tout cas pour ce qui est du du grand
reportage euh c'est l'idée de de bah sur
place bah voilà, on essaie d'être euh
d'être à la hauteur, on essaie d'être la
à la hauteur de l'histoire parce que ce
qui ce qui nous intéresse, c'est de
c'est de raconter l'histoire et
l'histoire en marche, l'histoire au
moment où elle se fait. Moi, j'ai eu la
chance de passer le mois de juillet, une
partie du mois de juillet à Kabou, à la
veille de de la reprise du pays par les
taliban, d'aller rencontrer les talibans
qui nous racontaient et qui nous
expliquaient. Ah mais Kabou, dans dès
que nos chefs vont nous donner l'ordre,
on va foncer sur Kabou et inchallah ça
sera très rapide. Bon, c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé. Donc là, on a on a
l'impression d'être euh dans euh dans
une histoire qui s'écrit et et d'en être
les témoins. Et et c'est vraiment pour
ça, moi je j'ai toujours fait ce métier,
c'est de c'est l'idée que euh on va
accompagner cette histoire-là, on va la
raconter euh le plus honnêtement
possible parce que ce qui est ce qui est
ce qui est fabuleux avec enfin la
guerre, ça n'a aucun
c'est c'est un truc horrible. C'est un
truc horrible de A à Z. Non, mais je
veux dire, il y a des gens qui trouvent
ça romantique et cetera. Il y a pas
Non, mais mais il y a une espèce de de
de comment dire de euh d'imaginaire
autour de euh de l'héroïsme et cetera et
cetera. Bien souvent,
je peux vous couper.
Oui,
ça c'est l'expérience du mec de terrain.
Est-ce qu'il y a pas un peu des
C'est pour ça que vous m'interviez ? Non
non, en fait, on veut boire des bières
après. Il nous fallait un prétexte. Bon,
d'ailleurs, on va parler des addictions
chez le grand reporteur. Euh,
on voit souvent en fait des des légendes
urbaines ou des choses qui ont besoin
d'être éclairci.
Tout le temps, on dit voilà les
reporteurs de guerre, ils cherchent le
sang, ils veulent faire la belle photo,
ils veulent être payés à la belle photo
et la légende de on va accompagner
l'histoire
avec tout ce romantisme de la légende
qui va avec auprès cette cette histoire
de reporter de guerre, on la connaît
mais dans les faits, la plupart de de la
profession, c'est des mecs qui vont se
déployer sur place pour suivre
l'histoire, accompagner l'histoire,
avoir un regard critique pour faire
remonter de l'information.
ou c'est chasser la belle photo, chasser
le truc qui va faire une belle
couverture. C'est quoi ?
D'abord, ça peut pas être chassé le truc
qui va faire une belle couverture parce
que la la guerre en couverture, ça se
vend pas. Donc il y a il y a eu des
couvertures de paris match, des
couvertures de guerre bien souvent
présentant un soldat ou un ou une scène
je dirais un peu posée euh à l'époque de
la guerre d'Algérie, je me souviens de
certaines couvertures euh et assez peu
de sang en fait si parlait de de photos
de photos fortes ne sont en en
couverture du journal.
Mais ça veut pas dire qu'on en met pas.
Mais mais c'est assez rare en fait
l'idée de d'aller chercher. Moi je je
vais être très très honnête. Il y a
quand je dis accompagner l'histoire,
c'est tout ce que vous avez décrit.
c'est avoir la bonne photo en effet qui
va ouvrir le sujet, la fameuse double
d'ouverture qu'on a dans Paris Match et
qui en un un éclair quand la personne va
regarder ça, elle va regarder le titre,
hop, elle elle va rentrer dans
l'histoire euh et après elle va dérouler
le les 8 pages, 10 pages qu'il y a
derrière et qui traitent de la du même
du même conflit. Donc là, oui, on va
essayer de construire le sujet. C'est
c'est comme un un scénario. Moi je je
viens de faire réaliser donc ce
documentaire sur les talibans pour Canal
Plus. J'avais déjà cette écriture
visuelle. Ça ne m'a pas posé problème de
de la refaire de la scénariser de
scénariser cette histoire là. Et et je
pense que c'est ce qu'on fait
maintenant. La vérité aussi c'est qu'on
y va. On y va parce que il y a vous
parliez des addictions. Oui, il y a une
on aime ça. On aime ces terrainslà. Euh
il y a une C'est pas l'adrénaline que
vous aimez ?
Bien sûr que si. Euh bien sûr que si.
C'est c'est pas la première raison pour
laquelle on y va. Mais quand on a connu
certaines situations et qu'on a on est
toujours attiré parce que et puis il y a
il y a aussi le fait, on parlait des
univers périphériques, je veux pas faire
de gradation moi dans le dans les types
de journalisme mais euh il sont
très bien tout seul. Ouais
mais mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
euh il y a dans la dans la guerre donc
le le seul avantage c'est que les
personnes vous allez rencontrer des gens
peut-être parfois 10 minutes, un quart
d'heure puis vous les oublierez jamais.
Vous les oublierez jamais. Pourquoi ?
parce que euh ils vous ont raconté leur
histoire à un moment et il y avait pas
de filtre, ils avaient rien à vendre,
ils étaient pas là pour la promo d'un
livre ou pour la pour ou pour discuter
d'un programme politique. Vous voyez,
parce que ces ces gens-là euh et ben ils
étaient dans le malheur et ils vous
racontaient leur histoire et vous euh
vous avez rien à faire là. Euh vous sauf
d'être d'être la personne qui ramène
cette histoire-là et et ça c'est et ça
c'est merveilleux. Enfin, d'un point de
vue personnel, c'est merveilleux. Euh
après, oui, il y a euh forcément une
addiction à euh à des sensations fortes
euh qu'on ne vit que là-bas, qui sont
parfois qu'on essaie de décrire euh
notamment à nos conjoints, à nos enfants
et qui sont extrêmement difficiles à
décrire. euh ce sentiment de pourquoi on
revient toujours vers ces zones,
pourquoi on y retourne, pourquoi euh on
en rêve parfois euh pourquoi euh quand
on a passé un mois, 2 mois en France, on
se dit "Ah, j'ai envie de partir, j'ai
envie de repartir." Pas forcément pour
aller sur un terrain de guerre, mais
l'idée de l'idée du départ, l'idée de
l'idée de se jeter un peu dans le vide
quoi aussi he parce queil y a toujours
ça quand vous n'êtes jamais sûr de rien.
Il y a plein de situations, je pourrais
vous décrire, je vais pas les Mais où
vous partez ? Je je me souviens dans pas
forcément dans des terrains de guerre,
je vais vous prendre en l'occurrence le
le l'ouragan Caterina à la
Nouvelle-Orléan. Euh on est parti donc
avec Alvaro Canovas.
L'aéroport de de la Nouvelle-Orléand
n'était pas accessible. On est on a
trouvé un billet pour pour arriver à
Bâton Rouge. On a pris notre voiture et
on est rentré dans la Nouvelle- Orléand
juste avec notre voiture
à un moment mais de chaos mais
inimaginable. à un moment où euh tous
les t tous les les enfin il y avait des
des pillages partout. Euh il y avait euh
notre but c'était d'arriver au
centre-ville et de raconter ce qui se
passait à l'époque dans le super dô où
20000 personnes sont restées enfermées
pendant 4 jours. Euh voilà de de
raconter comment en fait la Nouvelle-
Orléance c'est un c'est c'est un truc on
l' on en a un peu on l'a un peu oublié.
Il il est il est très important.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ce qui s'est passé,
ça ça prouve que la nature est toujours
plus forte que l'homme. Tous les
scénaristes d'Hollywood ont imaginé des
histoires de volcans qui détruisent Los
Angeles, de fusées qui s'abattent sur la
terre avec Bruce Willis et cetera.
Personne n'avait imaginé une ville qui
coule. C'est ce qui s'est passé la
Nouvelle-Orléand. Le lac s'est vidé dans
la ville. C'est même pas le l'ouragan
qui a fait enfin l'ouragan a été
responsable mais euh ce qui s'est passé
c'est ça. La ville a coulé et une ville
qui coule bah ça s'était jamais vu. Donc
on on tombe face à un scénario
incroyable euh apocalyptique avec des
gens qui sont livrés à eux-mêmes et ce
pays de l'ordre à l'époque gouverné par
George Bouche les États-Unis s'avèrent
incapable de venir en aide à sa propre
population qui est enfermé dans la vie.
PE diversion
comment
pas mal cette petite diversion. est
intéressante parce que c'est ça a été le
début de la fin de bouche, on l'oublie.
Les addictions chez le reporteur de
guerre, comment ça se gère la descente
quand on rentre d'un théâtre d'opération
? Comment vous gérez votre descente ?
Moi, je me souviens d'un d'un moment où
j'avais pas du tout été prudent. Euh
c'était ça se passait en en 2000,
c'était 2002. Euh le journal m'appelle
dernier moment euh c'était un samedi
matin, j'attendais des des amis en plus
qui venaient passer le weekend chez
nous. Euh le téléphone sonne, je
décroche. C'est le le chef photo de
Paris Match, Guillaume Clavière qui me
dit "Ouais, tu as vu ce qui se passe à
Bali ?" Je faais vaguement de voir qu'il
y avait eu un un attentat horrible.
C'était le premier gros attentat après
le 11 septembre, le premier gros
attentat marqueté, revendiqué par
Al-Qaïda. Et et Guillaume me dit "Il
faut que tu partes, je t'ai pris un
billet sur Singapour Airline. Tu pars
cet après-midi." Donc déjà
première ou seconde ?
Comment ?
Première ou seconde ? que je crois que
j'y étais allé en business. Ouais. Et
euh mais après ça a été rapidement la
fin de ces voilà
pour cette petite aparté continuer mais
on l'a fait à un moment. Ouais. Et et
donc je suis parti donc à Bali euh comme
ça là en prenant en achetant des
fringues sur place parce que je suis
resté quasiment 3 semaines là-bas et et
en fait j'ai pas du tout été prudent
parce que d'abord j'y suis allé tout
seul. J'avais pas de photographe avec
moi. En l'occurrence, il y avait
tellement de photos euh qui du bon bah
qu'on a utilisé, on avait déjà pas mal
de choses, mais il fallait un reporter
pour raconter sur place et et je me suis
j'ai pris un hôtel le plus près possible
de de l'endroit où ça s'était passé.
Sauf que j'imaginais pas ce que c'était.
Euh c'était un comment tout un tout un
bout du quartier qui avait été soufflé.
Et quand je suis arrivé avec le décalage
horaire euh plutôt favorable, bah disons
que ça s'était passé très peu de temps
avant et euh et quand et donc j'étais
pas le seul journaliste, he il y en
avait déjà, mais euh mais je me suis
pris une chambre d'hôtel avec vue sur le
le sur l'endroit où il y avait eu le euh
ce que j'ai vu ensuite euh je suis
immédiatement allé avec des secouristes
balinés qui étaient là qui étaient
qui qui qui avait amené des blessés à à
l'hôpital, l'hôpital de Den Passard, je
me souviens, il y avait pas de chambre
froide, enfin, il y en avait une seule
chambre froide et donc il y avait les
200 cadavres de qui étaient alignés et
les balinets qui qui mettaient dessus
des des packs de de
glace pour éviter que pendant la journée
les corps se décomposent. Et puis après,
il y avait les blessés. Et les blessés,
ben il ressemblaient à des morts. Je me
souviens de de cette de cette vision de
de gens où on voyait leurs dents euh de
et toute la face était noire quoi. Euh
donc voilà. Et en fait là où j'ai pas du
tout été prudent, c'est de prendre un
hôtel juste à côté parce que la nuit la
nuit j'étais à côté du truc quoi. Et
c'était alors sur place, j'ai rencontré
des des journalistes sur place voilà, je
me suis
Pourquoi c'était pas prudent ? parce que
un endroit ils peuvent refaire péter une
bombe sur les secouristes
d'une part et puis même d'un point de
vue psychologique quoi. C'était j'étais
pas habitué à ça. J'étais pas habitué à
avoir autant de morts et voilà.
Combien de temps de carrière
là ? C'était en 2000 2002 donc j'étais
j'étais à match depuis 10 ans mais
j'avais fait la France, j'avais fait des
faits divers, j'avais fait quand même
l'ordre du temple solaire, enfin des des
choses assez assez intéressantes hein.
J'avais fait aussi j'avais passé près de
3 semaines à la maison d'Ar de Nanterre
aussi euh pour raconter le à l'époque
c'était pas les radicaux, c'était
surtout les mineurs délinquents. Mais
bon voilà, ça faisait partie des sujets
que j'avais déjà fait et puis euh et
puis voilà. Donc je suis parti et
c'était avant de partir aux États-Unis.
Donc
c'était quoi la question ?
Euh la question là que vous m'avez posé,
ben vous m'avez demandé, vous m'avez
parlé des addictions.
Comment on gère sa descente ?
Voilà. Ben c'est ça. Donc je vous ce que
je vous je vous raconte. euh le on gère
sa descente en se disant euh à l'époque
donc je suis revenu, j'ai j'ai pris
l'avion, je suis arrivé à 6h du matin,
je me souviens et euh et j'ai dit à ma
femme en arrivant je vais absolument euh
amener les enfants à l'école parce que
je pensais que euh après avoir vécu ça
vite il faut que je alors bon et en plus
les le le sentiment un peu de coupable
d'être un papa absent ou en tout ou éva
naissant ou un papa euh pire euh bon
avec qui on sur sur qui on ne peut pas
compter, ça c'est c'est aussi quelque
chose hein.
On reproduisait peut-être
peut-être oui ce que je vous ai dit au
départ euh le fait de partir de prendre
son sac et et de et de dire au revoir
ciao. Euh donc oui, ça c'est ça fait
partie des des des choses qu'on qu'on
des des des poids qu'on fait peser sur
notre entourage, sur nos conjointes, sur
nos enfants. Mais bon là en
l'occurrence, moi je voulais compenser
en me disant vite faut que tu te
remettes dans le truc, ça va te chasser.
Et en fait pas du tout. Je me suis
retrouvé dans la classe avec les papas,
les mamans, la classe avec les tons
pastels. C'était c'était un clash total
par rapport Je me souviens, j'ai j'ai
déposé ma fille, je me suis assis sur un
banc euh presque pour reprendre mon
souffle. Euh voilà. Et après euh il se
passe toujours un un moment où euh on
veut être agréable évidemment avec tous
ceux qui sont autour de nous et on
s'aperçoit aussi que la vie euh la vie
continue quand on n'est pas là. Euh donc
on n'est pas vraiment indispensable non
plus. Donc il y a il y a un petit
réajustage auquel on n'est absolument
pas préparé quand dans les premiers
temps. Après on fait un peu plus
attention. Il y a aussi une chose qui
est qui est importante, je pense, c'est
le le le dialogue qu'on peut avoir quand
on est au téléphone euh
dans dans des pays comme l'Irak ou la
Syrie ou autre. Euh je me sais je sais
par exemple que je je m'étais peut-être
il faut toujours essayer de trouver les
mots mais en même temps on les a pas
toujours. Euh je je partais de de
d'Alep, j'étais à Alep et et j'appelle
ma femme et je lui dis euh je lui dis je
suis voilà on devait aller fêter un
anniver son anniversaire euh en gros je
la plante et je lui explique que je peux
pas sortir d'AP parce que il y a trop de
bombardement.
Et là elle vous dit tu m'en as trouvé
des pipot pour pas venir ?
Non c'était pas le c'était pas le ton.
Euh mais euh voilà euh c'est en fait euh
on quand quand vous dites il y a trop de
bombardement, évidemment que la personne
s'imagine que vous allez vous faire
écraser ou euh voilà et et aussi il y a
toujours cette perception qui est liée
finalement au à l'actualité H24 quand il
y a une news très forte, quand il y a
quelque chose qui se passe euh intense,
quand il y a une guerre quelque part,
les gens s'imaginent quand ils voient
des films également, il ils s'imaginent
que là-bas ça bombarde tout le temps.
Qu-ce qu' y a toujours un mec qui est
mort, il y a toujours une tuerie, un
truc et cetera. Et en fait, en réalité,
non. Il y a beaucoup de moments où on on
se fait chier. Oui.
Quand on accompagne les soldats, il y a
des temps où il se passe absolument rien
et vous êtes dans un pays où il se passe
où il est censé se passer un truc
incroyable, enfin
un cataclysme. Et en réalité non. C'est
pas tout le temps comme ça.
Elle fait quoi votre femme sans
indiscrétion ? Alors euh ma femme
actuellement, enfin moi je je suis euh
je suis euh séparé de la de la euh de de
la mère de mes mes deux premiers enfants
et séparé aussi de la mère de mon
dernier. Donc euh mais elle s'occupe,
elle fait euh euh la la première
travaille dans la télé et la deuxième
travaille euh s'occupe d'une association
euh d'aide aux parents d'enfants
prématurés. Donc elle est aussi dans une
partie avec des moments difficiles et
c'est pas c'est pas simple. Voilà.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour gérer sa
descente ? Ben, il y a pas de de En fait
euh
je pense qu'il faut euh
j'insiste sur cette question parce que
nous tous nos potes reporters de guerre
je dirais pas tous mais 99 % quand il
rentre c'est il se charge la gueule.
Ouais, je vais pas je vais pas vous dire
le contraire, mais euh mais euh euh
c'est sûr que c'est une c'est c'est un
passage difficile. Oui. Oui. Euh c'est
des moments où on est entre deux mondes
en fait et on c'est exactement enfin ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est quand on va
dans certains endroits, c'est comme si
on était sur une autre planète et on n
pas forcément les mots ni les
circonstances pour expliquer réellement
ce qu'on a vécu. Donc on garde ça pour
soi. D'où évidemment le besoin de
décompresser, d'où évidemment le besoin
de de
voilà
qu'on peut pas verbaliser, on peut pas
le ressentir à sa juste valeur. Non. Et
puis après, il y a de l'usure aussi de
ce genre de choses. Euh il y a des
moments euh je vous parlais des des des
cadavres de balie, mais il y a il y a
d'autres moments beaucoup plus
difficiles. C'est par exemple de euh de
voir quelqu'un mourir. Euh c'est quelque
chose qui est euh euh
voilà qui qui qui reste en vous, quoi.
Euh al je dis pas que ça m'est arrivé
des mais mais ne serait-ce qu'une fois
euh
voit la lumière s'éteindre.
Ouais. De voir
vous parliez tout à l'heure des des
photos. Je vais revenir aussi sur les
photos. Vous disiez
pas tout de suite la diversion. Non,
non, non, non, c'est pas une diversion,
c'est la photo euh euh citonnez-moi de
de vous reten tourner le euh le le
cliché, mais vous dites les photos
sanguinolantes. Mais en fait, en
réalité, les photos les plus
sanguinolantes sont pas les photos les
plus violentes. Les photos les plus
violentes parfois c'est un regard, c'est
une petite fille qui passe et tout de
suite on comprend on comprend en
regardant cette personne
toute la tragédie. Il y a il y a il y a
pas besoin de sang nécessairement pour
pour exprimer la violence dans une
photo.
Comment on fait pour vivre tous les
jours avec cette schizophrénie
de perception ? dire vous êtes beaucoup
plus concté à la réalité du monde que
n'importe quel pékin qui n'a pas le
temps de se connecter.
Comment on fait pour ne pas être un
fantôme au milieu des pseudos vivants ?
Euh
c'est bien senti des fois ce regard
quand vous posez ce regard sur une chose
Ouais.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ? Oui.
Oui. Non, on n'est pas on n'est pas des
fantômes. On a on est des gens plutôt
équilibrés. Il y a des passages
difficiles, mais la plupart des
reporters que je connais euh ont des
familles. Ce sont pas des gens qui dans
le Non, mais et même si oui, il y a
beaucoup de divorce mais on a des
familles, on a une structure sur place,
on est on est câblé mentalement. On
n'est pas des gens qui vivons quand une
fois que c'est terminé, ça y est,
comment on peut être câblé face à la
mort, face à la décrépitude de la guerre
? tout simplement poser une question de
salubrité mentale. Euh on est obligé euh
d'avoir ce ces racines. Euh si on les a
pas euh euh tout ça peut nous emporter
très vite euh souvent
parce que c'est totalement absurde
parce que des reporters de guerre euh
qui qui sont poches qui qui qui têtent
de la bouteille un peu plus que
d'habitude, il y en a plein.
Des reporters de guerre qui carburent à
l'opium, il y en a plein.
Des des reporters de guerre qui
carburent au whisky, il y en a plein. à
la couque, il y en a plein.
Vous en avez vu ça ?
Oui, oui, j'en ai vu bien sûr. Oui, oui.
Non, non, mais je je ne
c'est sûr que il y a une fellure qui
peut qui finit par se produire. Euh il y
a des des euh il y a des circonstances
qui font que euh on reste blessé euh par
un certain nombre de de de choses qu'on
a vu ou qu'on a vécu. Euh des des
circonstances qui vous euh euh
je vais vous dire le le l'un des plus
terribles combats moi auquels j'ai été
confronté, c'était pendant la bataille
de Mossou. J'ai pas couvert la bataille
de Mossou de façon extensive he mois.
J'y suis resté 4 jours et euh pendant
ces 4 jours, je crois que j'ai vécu les
combats les plus intenses que je vivrai
jamais dans ma vie. En plus, en étant
avec une armée euh donc en l'occurrence
une armée l'armée iraakienne euh et
pendant les trois premières heures au
moins en se disant euh d'habitude en
général on est avec l'armée qui qui va
gagner quoi ou qui va voilà
comme d'habitude.
Non mais
le journaliste, il sait choisir son
camp, c'est ça ? Non, c'est pas ça.
C'est c'est le journaliste, il fait en
fonction des circonstances et
croyez-moi, c'est bien difficile
aujourd'hui de le faire avec la la
l'exception de l'Afghanistan.
On va on va revenir sur les conditions
de travail.
Voilà. et et l'Afghanistan est un
terrain terrain de de journalisme
extrêmement intéressant dans la mesure
où pendant longtemps et encore à mon
avis aujourd'hui, on peut aller dans
plusieurs camps. Vous prenez la Syrie,
c'est pas possible d'aller dans deux
camps. Vous prenez l'Irak, vous avez pas
allé du côté de Daesh et du côté de
l'armée iraakienne dans le même crimé,
c'est pareil.
Oui. Voilà. Donc ça c'est extrêmement
problématique. Mais
pourquoi il y a pas il y a il y a ça ?
Mais pourquoi il y a ça ?
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Alors, j'ai
l'impression que les youtubeurs, c'est
un peu plus cool. C'estd que nous, on
peut se balader un peu mieux que les
journalistes. C'est-à-dire que les doc
ne nous identifient pas comme ennemis ou
potentiellement ennemi. C'est
comment ça se fait que le journalisme
maintenant quand on on entend ou on voit
que le journalisme n'est plus considéré
comme neutre sur les théâtres
d'opération. Avant, il y avait quand
même l'ura du journaliste et puis
maintenant ça a changé. C'est soit on
suspecte que il y a des services de
renseignement derrière. Ça a toujours
été le cas ça.
Oui, mais ça on va on va dire parce
queil y a un un de chez vous qui a bossé
pendant des piges, on l'a fait parler.
Et donc le le
comment on explique ça ? Comment la la
profession de journaliste est devenue
pratiquement persona,
sauf dans les tours de Daesh ou dans les
tours organisées par les les armées en
faction. C'est un un tourncouillon. Les
talibans.
Oui. Non mais pas les talibans. Il y a
aussi quand on va se balader avec
l'armée américaine, c'est un tour de
couillon.
Quand l'armée russe fait des des
balades, c'est tournent couillon.
Quand les Ukrainiens font des balades,
c'est ils tournent couillons.
Mais
comment on fait ? Comment ça se fait que
le journaliste un n'est plus libre sur
le terrain, deux est devenu une [__]
de cible ? Comment ça se fait ? C'est
parce que il y a eu trop de nonchalance
dans la profession. Vous êtes trop fait
infiltré par les services de
renseignement ou ou
je crois je crois pas que le le la donne
des l'infiltration des service de
renseignement est été est été le facteur
majeur. Les services de renseignement
ont utilisé pas mal d'ailleurs des des
légendes en se faisant passer pour des
journalistes. C'est arrivé euh moi je me
souviens d'avoir eu des problèmes avec
une milice chite en Irak. il nous disait
"Vous êtes journaliste CIA quoi ?" Bon,
j'étais avec un photographe américain,
voilà, il a fallu se dépétrer, il a
fallu parlementer, on n pas été oage
mais ça a été compliqué et on a passé
quelques heures désagréables, mais
immédiatement, on était estampillé
effectivement service, espion.
Voilà, ça c'est des choses qui peuvent
arriver. Je pense par contre que la
neutralité qui pouvait exister au moment
par exemple de de des guerres au
Nicaragua ou ou à Panama où là les
journalistes avaient une sorte de les
les guerriers roses d'ailleurs aimaient
bien parce qu'ils savaient que ils
allaient parler de leur cause. Donc il
les amenait on parlait de des des
problèmes de couillon mais aussi à
l'époque bah viens avec nous tu restes
avec nous. C'était aussi un peu le même
le même scénario où on se fait copain
avec le journaliste parce qu'on sait
qu'il va ensuite ramener en Occident et
et faire parler de nous quoi. Tout
simplement. Euh de cet état de fête, le
journaliste est n'est plus non seulement
considéré neutre mais aujourd'hui il est
une cible. Il est une cible. Pourquoi ?
parce qu'il est estampillé comme
journaliste à mon sens d'un pays et
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un affrontement
au niveau international he qui est pas
forcément un affrontement djihadiste,
non djihadiste ou un un affrontement
entre le les la frange la plus radicale
de l'islam et puis l'Occident, mais en
tout état de cause, dans tous les
journalistes qui ont été euh fait otage
ces dernières années, il y avait la
donne du pays derrière, il y avait
l'idée de la négociation, l'idée qu'un
journaliste
Donc vaut de l'argent qu'un journaliste
sert à une rançon. He je pense en ce
moment à Olivier Dubois qui est oage au
Mali depuis avril dernier qui est le
dernier oage français actuellement. euh
donc qui lui travaillait pour le Figaro,
pas pour le Figaro pour Libération et et
pour un autre média que j'ai oublié mais
en tout cas il était correspondant et
voilà et et lui clairement euh les
négociations quand il va y avoir si je
souhaite qu'il soit libéré le plus
rapidement possible mais évidemment
qu'elles se feront avec le qued d'ors et
qu' et le quedé est déjà sur l'histoire.
Donc le le journaliste vaut de l'argent
ou alors faut l'éliminer ? Faut
l'éliminer pourquoi ? Parce qu'en
l'éliminant et ben on fait parler de
notre cause aussi.
Daesh, la et on laisse pas de trace.
Oui. Bah Daesh, non. Euh James Féet,
lui, il s'est fait décapiter devant
devant la caméra. Donc euh
paix à son âme, bien sûr, mais c'est
donc voilà. Donc être journaliste,
exercer cette profession aujourd'hui,
c'est en effet quelque chose qui c'est
prendre des risques. Avant, on en
prenait, mais il n'y a plus cette
neutralité et il y a toujours le le
l'idée. Ce qui ce qui est assez
intéressant, c'est que par exemple quand
vous discutez avec certains groupes
armés, les gens vous parlent et ils
savent que vous êtes français et il
s'adressent à vous comme s'il
s'adressait à un diplomate. Je sais pas
combien de fois j'ai dit à des des à des
des comment des types mais je ne suis
pas diplomate, je ne représente pas ma
France je ne représente pas la France.
C'est
vachement plus intelligent, il faut leur
dire.
Non, je suis journaliste. Je suis là
pour venir voir, raconter, témoigner. Je
suis pas là pour porter les idées ou la
position de mon gouvernement. Et et
c'est toujours comme ça. Les types te
disant "Allez dire à François Hollande,
allez dire à Nicolas Sarkozi". D'abord
je les connais pas. ni ni ni ni ni ni
Nicolas Sarkozi ni François Hollande et
le fait de dire allez dire euh
il y a pas de fumée sans feu mais en
tant que directeur adjoint de Paris
match ancien directeur adjoint de Paris
Match vous avez dû les croiser les
Hollandes et tout ça non dans les
moi non j'ai croisé Sarkozy une fois
lors de son voyage premier voyage aux
États-Unis
et vous avez loupé le croche patat ? il
était il était déjà très occupé puisquil
y avait non à l'époque c'était plutôt
des déboirs de de voilà et on voilà et
en tout cas il y avait il y avait eu un
c'était c'était l'époque Cécilia et
c'était compliqué pour lui à la chose
qui est beaucoup plus intéressante.
Euh vous avez noté que maintenant les
journalistes sont identifiés comme
prenant cause ou du moins identifiés
comme pays ou représentant d'un pays. H
comment ça se fait que les journalistes
ne sont plus représentants des peuples ?
Comment ça se fait que les journalistes
parce qu'il y a pas de fumée sans feu, h
comment ça se fait que maintenant c'est
journaliste encarté,
journaliste machin, journaliste qui
bosse pour un tel, journaliste qui se
met sous le robinet de l'information de
l'État,
des choses vous en connaissez plein des
comme ça qui attendent un petit peu
comme les chiens devant leur croquette.
Vous voyez le bruit de la croquette qui
tombe dans la gamelle.
Moi je pense que ce que vous dites là
est un vous vous mettez le doigt sur une
des dérives de notre profession.
Une
Oui. Enfin la dérive
la dérive principale, c'est-à-dire le
d'abord euh encore vous parlez de gens.
Moi moi si si vous
c'est quoi la charte de Munique ?
Comment
c'est quoi la charte de Munique ? La
char
Oh il faut que tu me répondes là. C'est
quoi la charte de Munique ?
La charte de Munique ?
Ouais.
Je ne sais pas. Ah. Non
non, je ne sais pas. Je
moi je veux te parler
pour faire une parallèle, c'est
l'équivalent du serment d'Hippocrate du
journaliste.
Oui. D'accord. Donc tu vois, mais la la
la le la chose dont je voulais parler
moi là pour te répondre pour répondre à
ta question, c'est euh le problème qu'il
y a aujourd'hui. Euh c'est que d'abord
on est dans un monde de
euh on est dans un monde où le
journalisme dévit vers le commentaire et
vers l'opinion. C'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui, il y a des gens estant
journalistes qui vont avoir un avis sur
quelque chose sans jamais aller dans le
pays, sans sans aller sur place. Je ne
prétends pas qu'en allant sur place, on
sait tout, mais je prétends qu'en allant
sur place, on en sait un peu plus que si
on n'y va pas. Voilà, ça c'est une
première chose. Ensuite, il y a aussi
une dérive que je retrouve parce que je
vais je je je j'en parle de temps en
temps avec mes étudiants de l'J ou du
CELA, c'est cette notion de journaliste
militant. Pour moi, on on peut pas être
on ne peut pas être journaliste et
militant. On est soit militant, ce qui
est respectable, ou soit journaliste. Et
journaliste, c'est être capable de dire
dans un de ses papiers euh des choses
désagréables même sur des gens que vers
vers lesquels nos convictions nous
poussent. Euh voyez,
il y a pas à avoir de agréable ou pas
agréable. Non non mais si il faut être
capable les
faits uniquement les faits
non mais les faits et puis surtout de
quand on quand on part sur un sujet
quand on on scrute le sujet quand on
quand on est avec les personnes
s'apercevoir que bon le camp ou les les
les les voilà les circonstances qu'on
décrive ne sont pas exactement celles
qu'on avait imaginé et pouvoir le dire
et pouvoir l'écrire. Voilà. Alors après,
il peut y avoir des
le pouvoir, on va pouvoir l'écrire, ça
on va on va on va revenir. Mais sur le
journaliste militant, il y a plus que ça
maintenant pratiquement.
Non, il y a pas plus que ça. Mais
bien sûr que si. Nous nous on les voit
bien où ils font leur petitte sauterie,
ils sont tous entre eux machin, ils
pensent tous la même chose.
Il y a encore des reporters avec qui moi
je n'ai pas de de j'ai j'ai à qui je
partage pas nécessairement leur opinion.
On a le droit d'avoir une opinion, on a
le droit d'avoir des convictions mais
qui font un travail et un boulot
impeccable. Il y en a au monde, il y en
a à Libération, il y en a dans dans dans
un tas de journaux qui font leur travail
honnêtement. Et je pense que
comment il s'appelle ?
Comment
comment ils s'appellent ?
Qui ?
Les gens à Libération, le monde qui font
correctement leur travail.
Bah comment je pense que quelqu'un comme
Anicojan par exemple fait un travail
exceptionnel et tout à fait honnête. Et
voilà. Euh donc je pense qu'une
photographe comme l'Orange G qui
travaille pour le monde fait un travail
euh euh extraordinaire. Donc euh je je
Ceux qui font pas bien leur travail,
c'est lesquels ?
Euh ceux qui ne font pas bien leur
travail, je dirais qu'on les trouve
plutôt de du côté de quotidien par
exemple, du côté de euh de de ces médias
qui sont de l'info mais en même temps
extrêmement tendancieux, extrêmement
puis qui vont chercher la petite bête à
chaque fois et qui vont pour ça non
l'infotainment. l'infotainement, tu
vois, on dira ça. Ouais, moi je je voilà
après c'est eux qui ont décidé ça, mais
moi pour moi, ça fait pas ça rentre pas
dans les critères du journalisme. Euh le
le le journalisme, vous savez, c'est ce
que disait Orwell. Euh le journalisme
c'est voir imprimer quelque chose que
quelqu'un d'autre ne veut pas voir
imprimé. Et il ajouté tout le reste,
c'est de la communication. Et le
problème d'aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on est
aussi toujours dans cette ambivalence
entre le journalisme et la
communication. Vous parliez des gens qui
sont payés, des des des types qui
appartiennent à des boîtes euh voilà ou
à des partis politiques et qui voilà qui
font journalistes
et qui font journalistes qui font
journalistes. Vous trouvez comment
influencer
c'est ça c'est la la réelle influence
ces journalistes du mo
je pense que le le média influence en
général les les réseaux sociaux
influencent mais la question de
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux des
traces de journalisme oui on peut sur
Twitter oui vous avez parfois des trades
qui sont très intéressants, très
documentés en ce moment il y a des des
journalistes qui font un boulot
incroyable sur le les procès du 13
novembre et et on lit comme les procès
sont par transmis donc on a on a les le
texte on a des des des aperçus, des
témoignages
qui donnent bien l'ambiance et ça je
pense que c'est un boulot essentiel.
C'est un pour la population, pour les
gens que qui que ça intéresse et puis
pour nous informer. Donc euh mais il
faut toujours le le le problème
aujourd'hui, c'est la hiérarchie aussi
de l'info. Euh quand on sait que une
catastrophe peut être totalement zappée
parce que il va y avoir comment une une
information futile mais mais tellement
people, tellement qui va émerger et que
tout à coup tout ça disparaît. C'est
c'est on a on a toujours du mal à se
dire "Oui, on peut pas garder ça à
l'actualité même s'il faudrait". Mais on
sait que bon, d'abord tout travail
journalistique est intégré dans un média
et ce média aujourd'hui avant il faisait
ça pour vivre, aujourd'hui il fait ça
pour survivre. Donc il y a beaucoup de
médias qui aujourd'hui ont on voilà
doivent euh forcément vendre, doivent
c'est tout ça c'est pas euh c'est c'est
une on est dans une économie euh des
médias qui se euh qui euh comment dire
se réduit et on est aussi
ça ça c'est pas un peu le le prétexte
des journalistes pour justifier en fait
leur état de décadence en dire oui on a
plus d'argent oui on est les crèves la
fin oui sauf que
moi je prends comme exemple, nous
on est financé uniquement par notre
communauté.
Quand ils sont pas contents, ils
viennent nous le dire. Financièrement
parlant, ils nous soutiennent ou ils
nous soutiennent pas. On demande pas de
subvention, on n pas la TVA. Du moins,
on a la TVA 20 % contrairement au
journalistes internet à 2.1.
On paye tout l'impôt et les journalistes
il disent "Oh là là, les gens ils aiment
pas machin, on fait pas bien leur
travail, ils sont pas passionnés." Mais
c'est de leur faute. Pourquoi ne pas
avoir une conduite introspective réelle
?
Si les médias ils crèvent, c'est qu'ils
font de la merde.
Non, je pense que
Est-ce qu'on est d'accord ?
Je suis pas tout à fait d'accord. C'est
pas parce qu'ils font de la Non, le le
problème c'est qu'il y a une
popérisation de la profession. C'estàd
que à l'époque où j'ai commencé, quand
on était journaliste, on gagnait
correctement sa vie.
Combien il gagne régiste somier là au
jour d'aujourd'hui ?
Euh je répondrai pas à cette question.
Pourquoi ? parce que c'est ça fait
partie c'est c'est pas c'est pas énorme.
Voilà, c'est tout ce que je peux vous
dire il gagnait euh Regisse le Somier
quand il était à match
et je gagnais pas non plus des mon et
des 1000. Croyez pas. Voilà.
C'est quoi c'est quoi le le la grille
salariale euh la grille de salaire euh
pour cette ce type de position ?
C'est c'est pas la même position
aujourd'hui que que je l'avais que
j'avais à Paris match. Et honnêtement,
je je voilà, je je suis tenu à des euh à
une certaine confidentialité là-dessus,
c'est tout. Mais ce que je peux vous
dire, c'est que je ne gagne pas des
salaires. J'ai j'ai un nombre incroyable
de copains qui qui ont fait les mêmes
écoles que moi qui aujourd'hui gagnent
bien mieux leur vie que moi.
Deux fois plus, trois fois plus.
Euh oui, oui, oui, oui, largement. Oui.
Et bon, ils ont choisi cette voix. J'ai
choisi cette voix. On on en a expliqué
les raisons tout à l'heure et moi je
m'estime et là je vais revenir sur ce
que vous dites, ce que vous avez dit sur
les journalistes pour pour dire que
c'est pas de leur faute. Moi je j'estime
avoir été mais largement largement
privilégié en travaillant à Paris match
de pouvoir partir sur le terrain dans
des conditions décentes. Vous m'avez dit
tout à l'heure oui tu es parti à Bali en
business. Oui, à l'époque il y avait
encore ça. Bon, non, non, mais si. Non,
mais c'est important parce que moi je
connais les journalistes qui sont jamais
partis en business et j'en connais
beaucoup.
Ils sont jamais partis tout court.
Oui, mais ça c'est pas des enfin ça
c'est c'est pas des journalistes ça.
Mais si il de toute façon le grand
reportage, il commence au coin de la
rue. Là, s'il se passe quelque chose à
Paris ce soir, c'est sûr que moi je vais
je vais rester le jour du 13 novembre,
ça s'est passé. Voilà. Donc il y a pas
besoin nécessairement d'aller euh à
l'autre bout du monde pour faire un
grand reportage. Voilà
voir la misère, voir la
Non, ça existe chez nous. Euh on a vu
l'épisode des gilets jaunes a été aussi
une manière pour beaucoup de
journalistes. Comment
on va reparler des gilets jaunes.
Oui, mais ça a été une manière pour
beaucoup de journalistes, parfois
certains ayant cette ambiguïté du
journaliste militant mais pour beaucoup
de journalistes aussi de trouver un
terrain d'expérimentation, un terrain de
photographie aussi. Il y a eu beaucoup
de jeunes photographes. Euh le les
printemps arabes aussi ont été
pourvoyeurs de talent en photographie.
Il y a toute une génération euh qui est
qui est née avec les printemps arabes.
Certains d'ailleurs ont fini
tragiquement. Je pense à à Réi Hoslik en
particulier,
à Lucas Dolega Lega qui ont été tués le
premier en en en Syrie et le deuxième en
en en Tunisie. Donc voilà, ça c'était
des jeunes photographes qui ont fait
leurs armes avec ces ces pays qui
étaient c'était des voyages qui étaient
pas très loin avec les gilets jaunes.
Beaucoup de photographes aussi ont pu
voilà faire des manifes. C'est ça leur a
donné. Mais euh beaucoup de photographes
euh en effet euh n'ont pas forcément les
ressources financières et même euh des
gens chevronnés euh des Patrick Chauv,
je me souviens que Patrick me disait que
euh il avait couvert la guerre en Libye,
il était revenu, ça lui avait ça lui
avait rapporté 30 €. Voilà, il passé un
mois. Donc n'allez pas me dire que il
l'avait vendu, je crois à VSD son sujet.
Mais euh nez pas me dire que c'est un
métier qu'on fait pour gagner de
l'argent. Je dis rien, je pose des
questions.
Voilà. Et et la la l'idée de la
popérisation, c'est dangereux. C'est
dangereux. Pourquoi ? Parce que à la
place de ça, qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
domine ? Il domine des gens qui sont
derrière leur ordi, qui commentent et
qui d'ailleurs parfois vous désinglent
gratos, tranquille, peénard et qui se
font des noms et qui ont un nombre de
followers incroyables et qui font un
travail finalement qui n'est pas
connecté à la réalité. Euh et et et le
le le on on cette cette dérive, moi je
pense elle peut être corrigée s'il y a
des marqueurs véritablement de l'époque
qui sont des journaux euh qui vérifient,
des journaux qui vont sur place, des
journaux qui continuent à envoyer les
reporters
au moins trois noms.
Bah
pas Paris match, on écarte Paris match
tout de suite.
Pourquoi on écarte Paris Match ? Mais je
pense que c'est fait partie de sa
mission. Enfin c'est fait qui reste
Paris Match. Qui d'autre ? Non mais je
vous donneris l'exemple de d'Anj au
monde, c'est évident, le Figaro est un
très très bon journal. Le Figaro est un
excellent journal avec d'excellents
reporters. Je pense à Adrien Jaum, je
pense à Jean-Christophe Buisson, même
les les papiers, même si c'est pas
purement un reporter, mais les papiers
de Sylvain Tesson quand il va au
Carabar, moi j'ai couvert la guerre au
Carabar de l'autre côté côté
azerbaïdjanis. Donc j'avais une autre
vision du conflit mais les papiers de
tesson sur le Carabar et sur l'Arménie
étaient magnifiques. Donc ça c'est
important que ça continue à exister.
C'est important qu'il y ait encore des
gens qui aillent sur place parce qu'il y
a trop de gens derrière des machines. Il
y a trop de gens aussi qui parlent à des
types au bout du monde et les types au
bout du monde ben ils leur racontent un
peu ce qu'ils veulent.
Ça c'est la question internet. Il en
pense quoi du fait que les rédact n'en
voi plus de photographes préférés
prendre il préfèrent prendre des
correspondants sur place.
Alors, le problème des correspondants
sur place, c'est que par la force des
choses, à certaines époques, en Irak, en
Syrie, bah il n'y avait pas d'autres
possibilités. Il y avait pas d'autres
possibilités pour couvrir un camp ou
l'autre que d'avoir des gens qui
viennent du cru. Donc, il y a eu des
photographes en Irak qui se sont révélés
et qui ont sont devenus photographes
d'Apé. Je pense aussi à Sam Samir Aldoui
en en Syrie aussi qui a qui a couvert la
bataille d'Aleppe côté rebelle.
Il y a eu un certain nombre de gens Sami
Kets, mais lui il était plus chevroné
plutôt côté gouvernement mais qui a fait
aussi un travail remarquable. Donc il y
a il y a des gens qui viennent de là-bas
et qui sont des des des locaux qui qui
ont émergé de de ces conflits par la
force des choses parce qu'il n'y avait
plus de possibilité d'envoyer des
reporters occidentaux. Soit parce que
c'était trop dangereux, qu'il y avait
des risques de kidnapping ou des risques
de finir malheureusement comme celui
qu'on dont on parlait tout à l'heure,
James Famime.
Alors vous êtes vous êtes prof pour
journalistes ?
Oui.
Et comment on leur explique comment on
se défend contre l'autocensure et la
censure du N + 1 ?
Alors comment se défendre de
l'autocensur ? Le N + 1 en l'occurrence
chez moi, bah c'était le directeur de
match euh quand j'y étais. Euh le
directeur de match, c'est quelqu'un qui
a été euh euh qui a avec qui j'ai
travaillé 20 ans bien avant qu'il soit
directeur et euh et que moi je sois euh
directeur adjoint. Euh
j'ai pas véritablement vécu de censure
de sa part. Euh j'ai pu Non, non, mais
attendez, attendez, je laissez-moi
finir. Euh j'ai pas véritablement vécu
de censure de sa part dans le sens euh
il y avait une confiance euh et j'ai
ramené des sujets euh euh
problématiques euh parfois.
Lequel ? Bah la Syrie hein, mon travail
en Syrie a été extrêmement critiqué
parce qu'en Syrie, si figurez-vous qu'il
y a quand même un certain nombre de gens
qui considèrent que d'aller euh du côté
de Bachar Al-Assad euh c'est pas du
journalisme. Que d'aller du côté de
Bachar Alassad, quoi qu'on voit, quoi
qu'on fasse, quoi qu' s'y passe, euh il
ne faut pas en parler.
Mais c'est qui ces gens ? Euh
c'est un certain N.
journalistes.
Oui, c'est des journal, il y a certains
journalistes. Oui, oui, il y a certains
journalistes.
Jalistes qui vous empêchent d'aller
prendre la parole de quelqu'un d'autre.
Oui, tout à fait. Alors sur les
interviews de Bachar Alassad, on peut
bon journaliste ça.
On peut on peut revenir on peut revenir
là-dessus. Moi, je l'ai j'ai eu le
l'occasion de l'interviewer. Je ne crois
pas que qu'un journaliste honnête qui
dit "Demain, tu as tu as l'intérêt tuas
tu as tu peux interviewer Bachar Alassad
qui va dire "Ah non, non." Or, certains
nous, on l'a pas fait. Nous, on l'a pas
fait. Nous, on l'a pas fait
parce que il voulait pas que ce soit en
direct et il nous a dit il faut au
minimum une demi-heure de décalage sinon
on risque de se prendre des bombes sur
la tête.
Je vous laisse terminer.
Non, moi ce que je vous dis c'est le le
il y a un contexte, il y a un climat. Si
on veut revenir sur la Syrie, euh
rapidement la narration faite autour de
ce conflit euh est devenue un fantasme.
C'est-à-dire que euh
on peut pas nier que les forces
syriennes, c'est pas les plus blancs,
hein.
J'ai pas nié, j'ai panié, mais c'est
c'est important que vous me laissiez
exprimer euh comment on en est arrivé à
500000 morts, euh comment on est arrivé
à un pays en ruine au bout de 10 ans de
conflit. Euh quand je suis en Syrie, moi
j'ai essayé d'expliquer ça. J'ai essayé
c'était c'était mon light motif. Euh
quand j'ai interviewé Bachar Alassad,
c'est j'ai essayé de comprendre qui
était le bonhomme, euh qui j'avais en
face de moi, euh comment il avait pu
faire ça. Euh
après que j'y sois parvenu ou pas
parvenu, c'est à l'affaire de de chacun.
Mes reportages sont en ligne, on peut
les regarder, on peut regarder tout ce
que j'ai écrit, tout ce que j'ai dit.
En revanche, ce que je ne supporte pas,
c'est les gens qui m'ont critiqué
d'aller le faire. Voilà, c'estàdire de
moi, mon boulot, c'est d'aller parler à
des gens, à ces gens-là, même si ce sont
des assassins, même si ce sont des gens
qui ont du sens sur les mains.
Je suis allé passer plusieurs jours avec
les talibans en juillet. Les talibans,
vous savez, c'est le groupe djihadiste
le plus meurtrier des 10 dernières
années en terme de nombre de morts.
Voilà, j'étais avec des gens qui étaient
plutôt sympathiques
dans leur approche. Enfin, quand je
discutais avec eux, euh ils ne m'ont pas
fait de mal. Il y a eu quelques petites
tensions, on le voit très bien dans le
dans le documentaire, notamment quand on
veut accéder à des zones où il y a des
femmes, quand on les confronte par
rapport à leur voilà euh on prend des
risques. Oui. En étant avec les talibans
parce que on est avec un groupe de
talibans, il suffit qu' a vous savez en
Afghanistan, c'est vous êtes sous la
protection d'un d'un chef de guerre ou
d'un commandant. Euh s'il y a un un
autre commandant qui arrive et ça a
failli nous arriver à un moment euh
qui n'est pas au courant qu'il y a des
journalistes, ça peut très mal se
passer. Et c'est comme ça que certains
de mes confrères ont pu se retrouver au
tage parce que tout à coup il y a un
truc et tout à coup il y a une zone une
zone grise et là on peut se retrouver
très très dans dans une situation très
périlleuse. Mais euh l'idée d'aller voir
les talibans me paraît essentielle de la
même manière que l'idée d'aller voir
Bachar Alassad. C'est-à-dire que on peut
pas continuer éternellement à appliquer
sur la Syrie une vision qu'on en a de
l'extérieur. Et en plus le camp de
l'opposition qui au départ était composé
de gens d'authentique démocrates, de ce
camp-là a rapidement été gangrainé par
les islamistes qui n'ont plus accepté de
journalistes
indépendants entre guillemets. par
rapport à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure aussi sur le recul euh des
journalistes, en fait la la difficulté
supplémentaire, c'est que la plupart de
ces groupes armés ont des groupes de
presse en fait, ont des des officines,
publient leurs vidéos, publient leur
communiqués et ça se retrouve sur les
réseaux sociaux et c'est repris sur
d'autres médias et cetera et cetera.
Ça qu'en général les attentats sont le
vendredi soir parce que ça peut passer
au 20h.
Ouais, c'est
les attentats c'est plutôt le matin mais
mais bon et c'est après la prière en
général. Mais mais euh non, c'est c'est
voilà, on est dans un monde du H24
euh de du média tout le temps. Et et
dans ce dans ce monde là, mais les les
groupes armés, quels qu'ils soient, que
ce soit les forces azerbaïdjanaises,
la milice truc mûche dans les balcans
Ayat Tareral à l'IB, les même des des
des comment des gens du côté de Bachar,
toutes ces gens-là ont des organismes de
propagande qu'il où ils ont des
journalistes, où ils ont des gens qui
font exactement comme les autres
journalistes, qui sont là avec un micro.
Et pourquoi ils s'emmerderaient à
prendre des journalistes comme nous ?
C'est ça le le problème aujourd'hui.
Ils vous ont copié à peu près, c'est ça
? Non, euh j'étais assez euh j'étais
assez franchement ils on ils ont des
journalistes mais ils ont pas de
journalistes.
Ils ont des propagandistes.
Oui, j'ai j'étais mais il copie quand
même. Euh quand je suis quand j'ai
couvert la guerre au Carabar euh donc en
septembre dernier, euh il y avait un
moment une équipe de on était pas très
loin d'une ligne de front et on voit
arriver des types en hummer avec des
flammes sur le côté puis un insigne de
télé. Je pensais que c'était une télé
locale. Non non, c'était des Turcs.
Alors, ils étaient équipés euh comme des
comme des forces spéciales euh alors
qu'il y avait pas de combat là,
l'endroit où on était. Mais bon, il il y
en a eu un peu mais pas énormément. Euh
nous, on était voilà, on avait le
matériel qu'on avait mais là c'était
flambant neuf et cetera et il y a eu un
attentat sur un marché. Euh donc on est
arrivé quelques heures plus tard. Euh
ils interviewaient euh les gens du
marché exactement comme c'était le
modèle CNN. Alors vous madame ça
s'approchant d'une petite vieille euh
comment ça s'est passé ? Regardez, je
suis là. Enfin voilà le le mode qui a
été inventé
popularisé par CNN. Donc ils refont
exactement le même. Voilà. Et
évidemment, le but c'était de dire que
les Arméniens étaient des assassins qui
balançaient des euh des missiles sur un
marché et que les autres, au contraire,
c'étaient des anges. C'est ça le le le
problème aujourd'hui. C'était c'est ce
côté euh ce côté binaire euh absolu, euh
ce côté euh euh l'ennemi euh c'est
Hitler, c'est le mal et nous par contre
on est le bien. Voilà. Et ça, cette
vision là, malheureusement, elle
imprègne beaucoup de choses et elle elle
pénalise celui qui veut comprendre les
conflits. On en était juste avant, on en
était à les journalistes qui vous jugent
parce que vous faites vous faites votre
boulot.
Vous leur répondez quoi ? Vous leur
répondez ou
je leur réponds exactement ce que je
viens de vous dire. C'està-dire
bon le le comment va manger tes morts,
ça va plus vite hein.
Ouais, je je je trouve ça en fait c'est
déplorable. Ce qui est déplorable dans
cette attitude là, ça n'est pas de
critiquer le travail fait mais c'est de
critiquer le fait de le faire. Voilà. Et
ça c'est insupportable pour un
journaliste. C'est insupportable de
juger. Vous az essayé vous avez essayé
d'utiliser vos talents de journaliste
pour analyser
ces gens-là qui vous critiquez,
c'est-à-dire
les cribler, faire leur pédigré, voir
ils interagistes, avec qui ils
interagissent, où est-ce qu'ils vont se
retrouver, avec qui ils discutent. Vous
avez fait un peu leur pédigré ? Oui, je
veux pas je la la question c'est que
c'est aussi euh euh c'est exactement qui
c'est le journalisme de cours.
C'est du journalisme de cours. Oui. Oui.
Oui. Oui. Tout à fait.
Parce que quand quand vous les spotez
ces gens-là, c'est les mêmes.
Ils ont leur petites cordes de petits
militants qui vont avec. Hm
hm.
Et c'est du journalisme de
et des trolls aussi.
Ouais. Non mais ça c'est les militants
qui vont avec
c'est désagréable.
On vous filera un truc avant de partir.
Un truc hyper efficace
du du fait maison. Oui. Non mais si vous
voulez la la question c'est que tout
tout travail journalistique peut-être
faillible. On n' pas la science infuse.
Dans les écoles de journalistes, on fait
comment pour former des petits guerriers
indépendants,
sachant détecter quand ils se font
intoxiqués, pensant contre eux-mêmes,
alignant trois phrases sans faire moins
de de faute d'orthographe ou des petites
choses comme ça ? On fait comment en
tant que prof ? On les prend, on les
détecte où ils sont tous où c'est le
stéréotype de l'étudiant journaliste,
celui qui a fait une filière d'art, une
filière d'histoire puis va faire sa
petite filière journaliste. C'est à peu
près tous des mêmes petites clones
pour pour être caricatural, mais c'est
un petit peu, vous savez le le petit
léchecu premier de la classe qui se met
au premier rang pour faire des petits
crochepatttes à ses copains.
Est-ce que ça ressemble à ça les
étudiants journalistes maintenant ? des
gens qui ont énormément de vertus, ils
s'engagent pour une cause, ils sont
prêts à avoir ce sacerdoce, cette
malédiction.
Parce que voir un journaliste au 21e
siècle, c'est une malédiction.
Non,
pas du tout. Je pense que le le profil
que vous décrivez euh la plupart des
journalistes qui sont au CELSA ou à
l'ESJ par exemple, moi je connais pas
les autres écoles, je connais ces
deux-là, j'ai déjà fait aussi d'autres
conférences à Lyon I et autres avec des
des journalistes. Euh je pense qu'ils
soient animés par une passion qui
malheureusement et c'est là où je j'ai
toujours un un comment une peine quand
je les vois, c'est que je sais non,
c'est que je sais qu'ils trouveront pas
de boulot.
Voilà. Et je sais que la plupart euh
alors je leur dis toujours si vous
voulez vous accrocher, vous allez y
arriver. Je leur donne une un conseil
aussi. Je leur dit spécialisez-vous dans
quelque chose, commencez à enquêter pour
le jour où vous approchez un mec comme
moi de match ou euh
non, je sais plus à l'époque. Euh mais
le jour où vous approchez quelqu'un,
vous lui dites euh voilà, je voudrais
travailler sur tel sujet. Euh j'ai déjà
un contact avec machin, j'ai déjà
enquêté, j'ai déjà enfin en gros, je me
suis déjà investi. J'ai Il y a rien de
pire que un un un étudiant qui vient
vous voir et qui vous dites "Faites-moi
bosser." Bien sûr qu'on veut le faire
bosser, mais on veut d'abord qu'il
s'investisse. On veut d'abord qu'il ait
ce feu sacré. Il faut qu'il le montre.
Et euh et je trouve que les profils les
plus intéressants qui peuvent germer
justement de ses classes, c'est
quelqu'un qui a déjà euh euh une
expérience dans euh dans qui les sujets
environnementaux, mais des choses
précises. Un type qui va voilà qui va se
passionner pour les centrales
nucléaires. Aujourd'hui, on a besoin de
savoir pourquoi ? éolien ou pour les
éoliennes. Les deux, on a besoin de
savoir pour les centrales nucléaires
parce que le nucléaire ben on dit oui,
ça va être finalement c'est ce qui
pollue le moins et puis a et puis il y a
les écologistes qui disent non c'est
c'est ces nouveaux investissements dans
les centrales, c'est c'est de la folie.
Donc on a besoin de savoir quel est le
degré de fiabilité d'une centrale
nucléaire et on a besoin qu'il a une un
véritable une véritable enquête de fait
là-dessus. Euh sur les éoliennes, on le
sait un peu plus, on sait un peu plus
que ça euh les les 1300 MW d'une
chaudière nucléaire, elles vont
difficilement être compensé par un champ
euh d'éolienne. Euh fû-il euh euh fut-il
nombreux ? Euh fut-il euh très étendu,
ça sera très difficile. Donc le problème
c'est qu'il y a pas de compensation.
Mais ça, ces sujets-là, ça demande une
véritable enquête, ça demande d'être
passionné, ça demande de s'investir et
et je pense qu'il y a aussi aujourd'hui
des jeunes journalistes qui sont
capables de faire ça autrement que
d'aller promener un un un comment un
regard vaguement gauch sur une actualité
en faisant des commentaires, en faisant
finalement en donnant de l'opinion quoi
parce que finalement c'est de ça qu'on
crève aussi.
Je je vous parliez de la Syrie tout à
l'heure. L'autre jour, j'ai vu un
plateau
qui concernait la Syrie. Il y avait un
des participants qui était allé en
Syrie, mais bon avant 2011 et les trois
autres qui n'y avaient jamais foutu les
pieds. On en est là aujourd'hui. On en
est là. On est à à laisser parler des
gens sur des sujets, je dis pas qu'ils
n'ont pas la connaissance, mais ils ne
sont pas du tout connectés à une réalité
journalistique. Et une réalité du
journalistique, ça ne peut être qu'une
réalité de terrain. Si on arrête d'aller
sur le terrain, ça peut pas fonctionner.
On peut pas comprendre, on peut pas
comprendre l'état islamique. Je vous
parlais de la bataille de Mossou tout à
l'heure qui avait été un un moment mais
de comprendre la sauvagerie et et la la
puissance que ce groupe avait réussi à à
quand on ces qu jours à Mossou m'ont
fait réaliser que Daesh était une sorte
de de cerveau maléfique quelque chose
qui il y avait ce ce ces quartiers qui
étaient encore tenu par eux et puis et
puis tout en permanence le risque qui
est un véhicule suicide qui arrive et
qui percute la colonne avec laquelle on
était. Et encore une fois pour pour
revenir pour terminer sur Mosou, moi
j'ai je c'est la l'une des rares fois
dans ma vie où je me suis retrouvé avec
une colonne attaquant une colline avec
les types en face le lever du jour, le
soleil dans la figure. Donc nous on les
voyait pas et eux nous les vo nous
voyaient. Pendant 3h pendant 3h, on
s'est demandé avec mon photographe
Alvaro si euh
le mec de 25 ans c'était pas un petit
timbré. C'est ça qui avait planifié
l'opération. Non, on on s'est demandé si
on si on est si on allait gagner quoi.
On s'est demandé si euh voilà si les
quand les RPG ont commencé à on s'est
dit euh c'est vraiment mal barré. Donc
voilà. Donc euh c'est ça voir l'État
islamique, c'est aussi le voir euh quand
euh quand on regarde ce qu'il a pu euh
comment il a pu éventrer Palmirenter
Palmir voilà comment des gens euh qui
sont arrivés avec leur idée que tout ce
qui était euh pr qui pr euh qui était
avant l'islam devait être détruit. Euh
c'est c'est c'était c'était
inimaginable. Et en plus il l'avait pas
complètement détruit Palmir. Là aussi
c'est quelque chose que vous constatez
en allant sur place. Leurs émirs
vivaient dans Palmir. Pourquoi ? Parce
que c'est pas la coalition qui allait
bombarder les ruines. Donc ils ont gardé
quand même beaucoup de ruines. Ils ont
spectaculairement plastiqué le temple de
balle, le temple de balchamir et et
l'Arc de Triomphe. Mais ensuite, ils ont
gardé les autres et effectivement leur
le leur plus haut gradé vivait dans les
dans les dans les ruines. Voyez,
vous on parlait d'autocensure mais avant
d'aborder ce sujet là, est-ce que vous
avez reçu une formation au maniment des
armes ? Aucune. Non.
Est-ce que vous avez reçu une formation
?
J'ai fait mon service militaire, j'ai
tiré avec la fille belle. Voilà. Ouais.
Vous avez reçu une formation pour vous
échapper ?
Euh non non, je n'ai pas reçu de
formation pour m'échapper. Match,
c'était une formation du terrain. Il y
avait pas tous les stages. Moi, j'ai 53
ans. Je sais que la jeune génération
fait ces stages. Ça n'existait pas. Nous
quand on a commencé euh c'était euh on
va sur le terrain et on apprend
progressivement. Avec l'armée
américaine, j'ai appris à mettre des
gareau avec l'armée française aussi. Euh
voilà. C'est mieux dans l'armée
française, hein.
Euh c'est mieux pour les rations. Oui.
Et encore que les les rations
américaines, quand elles sont combinées
à d'autres ration, il y a des parfois
des des soldats qui arrivent à vous
faire des des petits plats. Il
a un McDonald's dans le camp, c'est plus
facile, hein. Il y a jamais eu de
McDonald's mais il y a eu en revanche
TJI et Friday éit une chaîne de burger
que le général McCrystal en Afghanistan
avait fait fermer parce qu'il trouvait
pas ça normal que les types qui étaient
au front dans des dans des postes
avancés n'avaient pas le droit au
McDonald's tandis que les autres
s'empifraient grassement à l'arrière.
Voilà
l'autocensure,
comment ça se combat
quand on est payé au lance-pierre ?
Quand on a un N+ 1 qui est plus militant
que le militant, quand on a des sujets
qu'on ramène et qui sont de nécessaires
pour l'intérêt général, quand on quand
on se reçoit du genre travaille sur
autre chose, tu feras quelque chose de
mieux là, c'est c'est mieux le chien
écrasé là, comment on fait ? Comment on
fait face à l'autocensure qu'il y a dans
les rédactions ?
C'est pas facile comme question.
Plaque la porte, on renonce à rembourser
son crédit immobilier, on se fait
plaquer par sa femme parce qu'on a plus
de tune. On fait quoi ? Ou sinon on fait
journaliste, on continue.
Mais il y a forcément un moment dans
votre vie, je vais être tout à fait
honnête, où vous avalez des couleurs.
Ah non,
forcément,
on peut pas être Non, mais il faut
tendre vers ça, mais il y a forcément un
moment où ben quand vous êtes dépendant
financièrement d'un média, que c'est
votre votre gagne pain et que ce que
vous avez vu, ce que vous avez écrit, ce
que vous allez essayer de faire, c'est
vous allez essayer de négocier. Vous
allez Mais bien sûr mais ça peut être
que comme ça sinon comment voulez-vous
le faire ? Vous n'êtes pas directeur de
la publication, vous êtes directeur
comment on fait pour négocier ? B
vous parlez on
fait pression
pression c'estàdire vous vendez votre
truc je vais t'envoyer les syndicats. On
parlera des syndicats dans la pression.
C
je crois pas que ce soit une question de
syndicat. Enfin, tout ça jamais été ça.
En revanche, je crois à ce sujet et je
crois que ce que j'ai écrit euh est la
vérité et je crois que c'est ce qu'il
faut publier. Vo mec, il vous regarde,
il vous fait "Écoute, tes petit malins,
ton petit 19 ans là, tu vas rentrer chez
toi et puis tu vas arrêter de me faire
chier." C'est ce qui se passe.
Euh, ça dépend si a il y a aussi, moi
j'ai connu des directeurs des infos, des
rédacteurs en chef qui avaient pas du
tout cette attitude là. Euh j'ai connu
des des gens qui au contraire étaient
euh euh plutôt dans cette euh si vous
voulez à match. Bon c'est c'est souvent
le le le pendant pendant ces 25 ans
passés à match, on me toujours dit euh
ah oui mais c'est un journal people avec
une couverture n naan. Ah oui, vous
faites machin. Oui, si on a fait ça, si
le la promesse éditoriale de match ça a
été de mettre effectivement une star ou
de mettre un comment quelqu'un de euh
glamour entre guillemets en couverture,
c'est aussi pour pouvoir vendre les 10
pages sur sur Alep, les 10 pages sur
C'est ça aussi parce que comme je vous
le disais, ces photosl fameuses photos
sanguinolandes dont vous me parlez au
début, elles font pratiquement jamais la
couve parce que c'est une catastrophe.
Les gens n'achètent pas. On l'a fait
avec la Nouvelle- Orléand que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure. Avec la Nouvelle-
Orléand Alain Genestar à l'époque il
avait fait la couverture. C'est le seul
hebdomadaire en Europe à avoir fait sa
couverture avec la Nouvelle- Orléand.
Mais ça c'est pas du tout vendu. Voyez
il y a de l'autocensure chez les Russes
? Vous bossez chez les Russes maintenant
?
J'ai aucune censure chez les Russes. Je
Ça fait un mois que j'y j'y travaille.
L'autocensure ?
L'autocensure non. puisqu'on m'a demandé
de parler de des mercenaires de Wagner
qui sont en train de faire des alliances
en Afrique avec le gouvernement malien
après avoir aider celui du de
Centrafrique. Un sujet extrêmement
sensible. J'ai pu dire qui était Wagner,
j'ai pu personne ne m'a appelé en me
disant attention machin. Non. Euh et je
crois que voilà maintenant voilà ça fait
un mois que j'y suis. Je n'ai absolument
pas senti senti de censure ni qu'on me
dise attention tu vas parler de Poutine
et cetera. J'ai parlé de l'Afghanistan,
des déboirs des Russes euh de
l'humiliation que la Russie a subi euh
en 88 en Afghanistan.
Mais là c'est facile, il y a
l'humiliation américaine là.
Oui, mais j'en parlais autant avant et
euh voilà.
Combien vous gagnez chez RT ?
Non, je vous ai dit que j'en parlerai
pas,
mais je vous ai dit aussi que c'était
pas euh une fortune. Voilà.
Euh question internet.
Quelle couleœuvre a-t-il dû avaler ?
question internet, c'est-à-dire ah mo
j'ai la communauté qui est devant moi là
qui pos des questions
euh c'est c'est plus
comme ça la brut c'est plus une certaine
lassitude de voir euh des hommes
politiques français je peux en décrivre
quelques-uns
constamment mis en avant dans le journal
constamment
alors en même temps match a toujours été
un journal légitim optimiste, hein, ça a
toujours été un journal, comment dire
qui est qui raconte l'histoire des
présidents, qui raconte leur avènement.
Donc, mais j'ai été Oui, moi ça ça me
lassait de voir des pages et des pages
surtout avec des articles et des gens
qui qui m'intéressaient pas. C'est c'est
ça que surtout euh au quotidien d'avoir
à vivre ça et parfois de devoir réduire
euh la pagination de sujets
exceptionnels pour pouvoir mettre en
valeur un certain nombre de nos hommes
politiques. Je peux vous les détailler
hein si vous voulez.
Est-ce que vous vous avez des souvenirs
de photos un peu bidonnées, truqué ?
Alors
avec notre ministre des affaires
étrangères, comment il s'appelle ?
Bernard Henry Lévi.
Euh ouais euh des photos de truqué avec
Mais je sais qu'il y a beaucoup de
photos avec Bernard Lévi quand il
apparaît dans un sujet, il apparaît
beaucoup de fois. Non, je crois je crois
pas. la la pertinence de Bernard Henry
Levi, je me prononcerai pas dessus mais
non parce que je considère pas qu'il
fasse partie de je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui a l'honnêteté parfois
d'attirer le monde sur un certain nombre
de problèmes avec sa notoriété mais je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
beaucoup de dégâts notamment en Libye et
que la question lui est pas
fondamentalement posée sur l'influence
qu'il a pu avoir sur ce conflit. Je
rappellerai que le conflit libien a mis
ce pays mais complètement exang a rendu
ce pays exang. Aujourd'hui, je suis allé
à Bengazi moi euh l'année dernière euh
je fréquente l'Irak, je fréquente la
Syrie, euh je fréquente l'Afghanistan.
C'est des pays où où qu'on soit, il y a
un ordre. En Libye, il y a rien. Il y a
que des milices. Les seules
infrastructures qui ont été améliorées à
Bengazi, c'est des casernes militaire,
des checkpoints, des voitures de flic ou
des voitures militaires. Tout le reste,
tout ce qui est réseau, services public
et cetera n'existe pas. Ça c'est le
résultat de notre intervention. Je
rappellerai aussi que à Bengazi, je sais
pas si vous vous souvenez, à la fin de
la guerre, Nicolas Sarkozi et David
Cameron sont venus célébrer la victoire
sur une fameuse place rebaptisée, place
de la liberté. Je suis allé sur cette
place, ce n'est plus qu'un tas de gravas
où des mendions viennent récupérer des
morceaux de ferraill au milieu. Voilà
l'œuvre civilisatrice qu'on a qu'on a
faite en en Libye pour des raisons
obscures sur lesquelles je reviendrai
pas, mais la conséquence de la Libye,
elle est encore pire. C'est-à-dire que
si on a eu le Sahel, c'est à cause de la
Libye.
On reviendra pas sur les les raisons.
C'était pas
c'était pas pour apporter la les les la
démocratie pour les petites filles.
Bah, on a vu ce que ça donnait, hein. 20
ans 20 ans d'Afghanistan et on redonne
les clés au taliban. C'est c'est voilà.
Donc la Libye, on anéantit le pays. Euh,
on a comme conséquence un déferlement
des armes des arsenaux de Kaddafi sur
l'Afrique. Euh des des coortes Toareg
euh miliciens libien euh de la Zawad qui
euh déferle sur Bamako et on intervient
pour Serval en 2013. On y est toujours.
Voilà.
C'est joyeux journaliste, non ? Euh
c'est Non, il faut pas Il y a des
moments on se marre bien. Euh
c'est quoi ? Juste après la cuite.
Euh non euh avant euh quand on arrive à
se faire un petit apéro à Caboule. Oui,
on aime bien manger une carpe. On manger
une carpe avec une
Oui, une voilà sur les berges du tigre.
Oui, c'est pas très bon la carpe.
C'est celle du tigre, elle est pas
bonne. Mais celui dans les petits
étants, elle est pas mal.
Ah bon ? Bah je moi je me méfie des
poissons de rivière.
Le goût de vase.
Voilà. Exactement.
Revenons à notre sujet. Euh
question internet.
Bonsoir. Que pensez-vous de Collatéral
Murder et des journalistes de Reuters ?
Quel aurait été son geste s'il avait été
à la place de Julian Nassange en
possession de cette vidéo ? Merci.
Est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
répète la question ?
Oui, surtout rappelez-moi le contexte de
Collatéral Murder. Alors, collatéral
murder, c'est simple, c'est cette petite
vidéo en noir et blanc prise d'un
hélicoptère où il y a deux gars qui
parle au micro qui se dit "Oh [__] tu
as vu le terroriste là ? Vas-y,
défonce-le, défonce-le !"
Mais le problème c'était un journaliste
avec son caméraman.
Ah !
Bon, il ressemblait hein. Vous voyez, on
voit pas grand-chose dans les dans les
caméras de d'hélicoptère.
Ouais.
Et vous vous rappelez en fait Collatéral
Murder, Julien Assange, il a sorti ça ?
Mais Julian Assange a eu un si je suis
très à l'aise pour parler de Julian
Assange parce que je pense qu'il a eu un
rôle
absolument fondamental
notamment sur la guerre en Afghanistan.
Ça a été
commencé quand votre grve de la fin pour
le faire sortir de tôle ?
Euh
je vais pas
Si vous commencez, je la fais avec vous.
C'est vrai ?
Mais vous avez un peu d'avance là. Vous
êtes un peu plus
Ouais. Non mais il y a eu le confinement
et faut pas déconner. Je pourrais
peut-être tenir 10 jours de plus. Et
c'est
commett Snowen pour moi c'est ça fait
partie ces mecs-l sont des véritables
héros
journalistiquement
Julian Assange c'est clairich on l' fait
cette grave de la fin
euh oui mais je pense qu'on va pouvoir
mourir et que personne va tout le monde
s'en foutra quoi. Et surtout surtout les
Américains et surtout les Anglais qui le
détiennent aujourd'hui.
L'exil de de Snowden aussi, c'est
quelque chose de de parce que ce qui est
intéressant dans leur démarche après on
les a accusé évidemment il y a eu des SM
campaign et compagnie contre Assange, on
lui a collé un viol et cetera. Mais je
je vais revenir je je vais revenir
vraiment sur euh ce que vous décrivez là
sur la vidéo. Alors effectivement,
dommage que c était des euh des des
reporters en tout cas des journalistes
qui qui euh qui a prononcé des paroles
pareilles. Je sais qu'en en Afghanistan,
il y a eu
pas c'est pas les journalistes, c'est
les mecs qui étaient dans l'hélicoptère.
Oui. Oui. Mais c'était un journaliste.
Non non, c'était des militaires.
Ah c'était des militaires ? Mais c'était
des journalistes qui les encourageaient.
Non non non non. C'était des gars.
C'était des gars, ils se parlaient entre
eux, il disaient "Oh, j'ai vu une
target. Allez, hop, on le démonte."
Oui, mais ça c'est arrivé plein de fois.
Ouais, mais si si moi je vous apporte
cette vidéo, j'ai sorti Si moi je vous
apporte cette vidéo que j'ai sorti de
l'armée américaine.
Imaginez-vous, je suis payé au lancepire
pour faire les pleins d'essence
d'hélicoptères,
ma hiérarchie me respecte pas. J'ai
accès aux bandes, je chore les bandes.
Je dis, je vais donner ça quand même
pour l'intergénéral. Je vais le donner à
un journaliste. Hm
hm.
Le journaliste, il reçoit ça. Il en fait
quoi ?
Bah, il le publie.
Non mais ce que ce qui s'est passé avec
Snowden avec pardon Assange, ce qui
s'est passé avec Assange, le premier
premier blot des Wikileaks, ça a été
la première explosion,
la guerre Afghanistan. La guerre
d'Afghanistan. Et moi, je me suis rendu
compte qu'un incident duquel j'ai été
témoin dans la région de Candar
en en patrouillant avec l'armée
américaine, en fait, cet incident là se
répétait un peu partout. Euh, ils ont
tué un gars estampillé taliban qui
n'avait pas d'armes qui soit disant les
a menacé. Voilà.
Il ils l'ont tué dans le dos, c'est ça ?
Ben, ils l'ont tué. Euh,
le mec dans
les circonstances, un de leurs gars
avait sauté sur une mine, avait perdu
trois membres. Tous les soirs, ils
avaient le gars qui était en Allemagne à
Langetool dans l'hôpital qui leur
parlait. C'était d'une tension extrême.
Ça s'est passé juste avant qu'on arrive.
Et au moment où on arrive, on entend un
coup de feu. Alors, il y a beaucoup de
coups de feu dans la campagne et la
patrouille qui était juste parallèle à
la nôtre tue ce gars. On voit le type le
soir et je commence à discuter avec les
soldats. Ça, je l'ai écrit hein, ces
choseslà. Et les soldats en fait,
j'aiécris j'ai écrit un bouquin
là-dessus comment il s'appelle ? Euh en
fait, j'ai écrit dans un sur la question
euh vous allez me dire ça, je l'ai écrit
dans mon papier à à l'époque,
mais j'ai écrit euh en fait, j'ai
analysé quelle était la situation d'un
soldat qui a une arme et à qui on
demande de tuer en expliquant que l'arme
est un un une sorte de vous savez dans
la Grèce antique, quand on
quand un
comment un type avait tué un animal
sacré
il y avait un jugement et puis
finalement on décidait qu'on allait
balancer le couteau dans la mergée parce
que c'était le couteau le le qui qui
était en fait l'acteur du truc. Et
l'arme bien souvent pour le militaire
c'est une sorte de de paratonire. C'est
un truc qui est, c'est à la fois une
protection et en même temps voilà et en
fait quand je suis allé voir les soldats
le soir qui avait fait ce qui en était
très fier qui me disait "Ah tu as pas vu
toi tu étais à côté mais on a tué ce
gars" et puis je commence à leur parler
dit ça. Ils ont dit ça ils ont si si
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr. Ils étaient
en short le soir, ils avaient enlevé
leur équipement certains étaient en
train de jouer à Call of Duty. Voyez
l'ambiance, on passe la journée en
patrouille avec des M16 et le soir on
regarde Call of Duty.
On joue on joue à Call of Duty.
Voilà, je suis pas gamer donc mais le ce
que ce que je veux dire c'est que
progressivement
je voyais les mecs qui commençaient à se
dire "Merde c'est un journaliste. Merde
le truc est pas tout à fait qu'on a fait
est pas tout à fait Je suis allé voir le
capitaine. Mais qui c'est ce gars ? ici,
il a été machin et cetera. Mais en
réalité cet incident là minime un homme
perd la vie. Bon euh mais ce qu' avait
prouvé euh à Sange, c'est que ce type
d'incident arrivait sur une voilà et que
c'était dans les rapports, voilà, et que
ce qu'on vendait de la guerre au
sénateur américain
chirurgical.
Oui. Non mais ce qu'on vendait de la
guerre au sénateur américain qui venait
visiter Kabou les trois quatre bases,
c'était le progrès, le D'ailleurs, il y
a eu beaucoup beaucoup de d'articles qui
ont été faits par la suite sur la façon
dont on a dont on a on a truqué cette
guerre. Donc on a on a essayé de la la
promouvoir dans le sens de
l'amélioration et on a dépensé enfin
quand je dis on les Américains 1000
milliards de dollars pour essayer de
maintenir à bout de bras un gouvernement
pour infiner l'abandonner en race
compagne en faisant une un deal de paix
avec les talibans et en prenant la en
prenant la tangente. C'est ce qui s'est
passé fait que 1000 milliards ont été
investis dans un truc où on n pas passé
notre temps où l'armée américaine, je
vais pas dire on, a passer son temps et
tous les think tank autour à vendre une
idée du progrès et de et des et des
comment des étapes qui amenaient vers la
démocratie en Afghanistan. Ça durait
très longtemps hein. Aujourd'hui, on
dira on avait arrêté depuis longtemps
avec le relais des journalistes.
Oui, bien sûr. Bah le le l'exemple de
Judith Miller pour vendre la guerre en
Irak, souvenez-vous, ça c'est l'écueil
du New York Times. Voyez, New York Times
qui reste quand même euh pour moi, même
si je pense qu'il a il est il est sujet
aujourd'hui à des dérives notamment sous
l'influence des mouvements W et et
indhygiénistes aux États-Unis, le New
York Times pour moi reste le meilleur
journal du monde.
meilleur journal du monde s'est comporté
de façon coupable dans dans le
déclenchement, dans la préparation de
l'opinion américaine à la guerre en Irak
avec des relais dans l'équipe Chenny et
cette journaliste qui finalement a a
servi de la propagande en fait, a servi
à préparer l'opinion américaine à cette
guerre. Voilà
la fabrication du consentement.
Oui, c'est ça.
C'est ça.
Oui, tout à fait.
Comment ça se fait que votre
corporation,
je dis votre parce que c'est la presse,
c'est votre pays, h
elle s'est pas un petit peu réveillé en
disant écoute, on va se calmer là, tu es
gentil, on sait où tu vas prendre tes
apéros, on t'a vu dans les les salons
feutrés du ministère de la défense. Là,
ça commence à faire beaucoup là. Bah, il
y a quand même une une sorte de
en fonction de la crédibilité du
journaliste. Euh
la crédibilité du journaliste, il y a il
y a un journaliste, c'était c'est pas
chez Spigle qui qui a trandé pendant des
années là.
Oui, il y en a eu plein. Il y a eu Jason
Blair aussi aux États-Unis. Enfin, il y
a eu un certain nombre de gens qui qui
écrivaient des choses qu'il n'avaient
jamais vu euh et qui avait un talon pour
pour truquer. Euh ça c'est un vrai
problème. C'est c'est un
revenons. En fait, les journalistes, ils
ils ont pas ils se sont pas élevés parce
qu'ils mangent le même vomi toute la
journée.
Parce qu'ils vont pas sur le terrain ou
Mais non, mais tous les journalistes,
je veux dire, il y a un certain nombre
de journalistes Oui. qui Mais il y a
encore des journalistes qui vont sur le
terrain. Mais il y a encore des
journalistes qui vont sur le terrain,
Dieu merci.
et et bien souvent il y a il y a des
prix qui sont distribués
pour des enquêtes qui sont impeccables
et qui et qui servent à quelque chose.
C'est c'est ça le le le l'intérêt, c'est
de de d'arriver
à se dire d'abord, moi je pense ce que
c'est ce que je dis souvent à mes à mes
élèves, c'est que et ça corrobore ce que
je vous disais sur Assad ou sur les
talibans, il ne doit pas y avoir de
d'endroit au monde quand on est
journaliste où on ne va pas, on
s'interdit d'aller. Si déjà on se dit
"On va pas, on va pas là-bas,
c'est pas une jour une démarche
journalistique. Il y a pas de personne à
qui on doit s'interdire de parler. On
doit pousser les portes. Toujours
essayer de de Prenez comment Gérard Dav
et l'homme le du du monde là.
C'est lequel qui est un peu dégarni ?
Comment il s'appelle ?
C'est Dav. H
lui il veut faire un octogone avec moi.
C'est vrai ?
Ouais.
Bah pourquoi ?
Mais il est pas équipé pour Je l'ai déjà
dit 15 fois et il est pas équipé. Bah,
je sais pas si je peux je j'appuie sur
un bouton sensible là, mais en tout cas,
j'entendais parler tout à l'heure de son
livre qu'il a fait sur Emmanuel Macron.
Il a procédé par sphère concentrique,
par défaut d'avoir accès au à
l'individu. Il dit que par rapport à
Hollande, Hollande, ils avaient pu avoir
des des
passer beaucoup de temps avec lui et que
avec Emmanuel Macron, ça avait été
beaucoup plus compliqué, qu'un certain
nombre de gens qu'ils avaient cherché à
qui ils avaient cherché à parler avaient
été brief par l'Élysée pour ne pas
pour ne pas leur parler. Enfin bref,
voilà.
Ça ressemble un peu à Bachar Elass
Assad.
Bah
non.
Pourquoi ça ressemble à Bur ? Ah
euh les proches ont dit de pas parler.
Il c'est difficile de l'approcher. C'est
difficile.
Mais bien sûr. Enfin Bachar Alassad
était estampillé par tout le monde
dictateur pas Emmanuel Macron. Chez jaun
chez les gilets jaunes, il quand même
empil dictateurs. Non.
Oui. Alors
est-ce que c'était de la de la
contre-insurrection ?
Là on parle du contrôle en fait de
finalement
c'est le même type de contrôle.
C'est le même type de contrôle
médiatique. Oui, d'une certaine façon.
Oui oui oui mais ça veut pas dire que si
vous vous avez accès vous allez pas y
aller en train
de faire un parallèle entre Macron et
vacha on se rassure bien mais en terme
de contrôle médiatique
oui si vous voulez
on est d'accord
ou bah ça veut dire que on filtre et
mais là en l'occurrence deux
journalistes qui voulaient faire ce
portrait n'ont pas pu aller jusqu'au
bout puisque ils n'ont pas eu accès à à
l'intéressé trava chez RT là maintenant
vous avez une carte de presse
oui
vous pouvez aller à l'Élysée ou c'est
toujours interdit ?
Je crois que c'est toujours interdit.
Faudra pas s'étonner que les Russes
fassent la même chose en Russie qui a
plus de journalistes français à
accrédité.
Bah c'est toujours le problème les
Russes après que les journalistes
français des problèmes pour accéder à la
Russie, c'est une réalité. euh et au
monde russe en général puisque c'est pas
simplement la Russie, c'est c'est
évident que bon là il y a une il y a eu
une histoire au début et puis ce qui ce
qui est très étonnant moi je trouve dans
le traitement d' RTRT euh je me sens
tout à fait libre pour en parler c'est
que au début
vous êtes obligé de le dire
non mais pas si je le précise parce que
vous m'avez demandé si j'étais sujet à
des
voilà
nov
voilà Mais mais je suis non seulement
pas ce sujet, mais ce que je trouve
dommage et et et peut-être que je sais
pas, peut-être que ma ma présence sur RT
en tout cas moi, il y a aussi l'idée que
la France et la Russie ont des destins
communs et que
période des selles s'arrête quand ?
Euh dans 3 mois.
Euh mais entre la France et la Russie,
il y a quand même beaucoup de choses en
commun et que malheureusement il y a des
gens si on fait une petite un petit
petite aparté sur RT sur
l'accès des médias et des conneries
comme ça. C'est ça. Non, non, non. Ce
qui c'est qu'en fait, il y a des gens
qui fonctionnent avec un logiciel de la
guerre froide, c'est-à-dire qui pensent
encore que les Russes sont cet empire
euh qui a une une idéologie queil y a et
en fait en réalité, quand vous visitez
la Russie ou quand vous vous faites des
reportages là-bas, je dis pas que tout
est libre et qu'on peut faire ce qu'on
veut, mais il y a plus il y a pas il y a
pas de porté idéologique. Il y a une
volonté de puissance de la Russie et une
volonté de de dire sa partition au
niveau international. Il y a une volonté
d'influence comme beaucoup de pays,
comme la Turquie, comme la Turquie qui
en pleine expansion la Turquie. Non mais
attendez attendez attendez attendez
laissez-moi terminer parce qu'en fait le
problème c'est que je peux pas euh si
laissez-moi juste terminer ça pas trop
coup c coupé quand même.
Non non mais sur sur l'idéologie en
Russie
il y a quand même il y a quand même une
grande frange
proche du pouvoir ultraationaliste.
Bien sûr mais attendez
je vous parle pas de patriote comme nous
on est au
il y a des gens qui ont un logiciel de
la guerre froide de l'autre côté aussi.
Ah non mais tout à fait tout à fait mais
le problème c'est que Emmanuel Macron
justement quand il est souvenez-vous de
ce qu'il a fait son premier acte en
diplomatie en en affaires internationale
ça a été
encore un coup de vent
non ça a été de de d'inviter Poutine à
Versailles ça été son premier voilà et à
partir de de là a été entamé un un
processus qui s'appelait le le dialogue
de Trianon qui restait l'être morte et
Macron au départ et régulièrement
d'ailleurs invoque la Russie d'ailleurs
il a dit qu'il fallait travailler avec
la Russie à la sortie des des Américains
euh d'Afghanistan. Le problème c'est
qu'on on est face immédiatement à une
diplomatie et un qu d'orsé qui lui tout
de suite braquait contre la Russie. Je
vous dis avec un logiciel de guerre
froide, c'est-à-dire avec l'idée comme
si voilà aujourd'hui on l'a vu, moi ça
c'est c'est mon point de vue personnel,
on a vu euh comment se comportaient les
Américains
méprisant leurs alliés.
départ d'Afghanistan sans prévenir
personne. Euh, rupture du contrat 56
milliards de dollars. Le plus gros
contrat d'armement jamais négocié avec
la France en France avec les
sous-marins. Euh je vous passe l'abandon
de l'achat des rafales par les Suisses
NSA, le scandale de la NSA, le fait
qu'il y ait des antennes auudess de
l'ambassade américaine à Paris,
plein plein de choses. les les alliés
méprisés, ça me paraît
mais quand même mais quand même pas nos
vies de choc.
Non, mais ça c'est autre chose. Mais
mais euh euh
le
du moins ça se voit pas.
Du moins ça se voit pas. Mais le ce que
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est une
occasion idéale à mon sens et je pense
que si le général de Gaul était au
pouvoir à l'époque, souvenez-vous le le
retrait de Gaulle en 67 euh du
commandement intégré de l'OTAN, euh il a
été décidé à une époque où c'était
encore plus difficile de le faire.
puisque là il y avait la guerre froide
et se retirer du commandement intégré de
l'OTAN, ça voulait dire ça voulait pas
dire se retirer de l'OTAN mais ça
voulait dire la France prend son
indépendance. Donc c'était c'était très
difficile à faire. Là aujourd'hui, on a
quand même une occasion de redistribuer,
de revisiter nos alliances. Euh, on a un
problème de l'Europe de la défense. Je
fais un petit peu de géopolitique, mais
on a un problème avec l'Europe de la
défense. On est nous français, on s'est
retrouver face au greurcs parce qu'on
était les seuls à pouvoir défendre les
Grecs parce qu'il y a pas d'Europe de
défense finalement. et on a failli
livrer une bataille navale aux Turcs.
Aujourd'hui, nos relations sont revenues
un petit sont redevenues un peu
meilleures. Mais il serait peut-être
intéressant en ce moment de parler à des
gens qui sont nos voisins. En plus avec
ce qui se passe en Afrique, avec ce
problème sahélien qu'on a sur le dos.
Alors évidemment les les les maliens,
ils jouent sur plusieurs tableaux.
Évidemment, il y a les Russes qui
arrivent et qui disent "Bah nous, on
peut très bien faire le boulot que
faisait l'armée française et mieux et
cetera." Bref, et en plus en envoyant
des mercenaires. Donc le le le la
problème aujourd'hui, c'est qu'on est
dans un il y a il y a on est toujours à
la remorque de ces Américains et et et
cet atlantisme permanent latent qui
existe dans la classe politique
française toute toute
journalistique et diplomatique et bien
cet esprit je pense qu'il faut il faut
évoluer. Je pense qu'il faut et voilà et
je peux je peux vous demander d'être
l'avocat du diable. Alors pas des
journalistes
mais faites faites-moi l'avocat du
diable du qu d'ors
pourquoi pourquoi on est toujours à la
la la 5e roue du caros américain ?
Pourquoi on est toujours dans leur trace
? Faites-moi l'avocat du diable. Essayez
au moins de leur trouver des des
raisons.
Je pense que c'est des des
rappelez-vous qu'ils ont payés avec
notre argent. Oui, c'est ça. Euh je je
dirais que
défendez-les.
Bah défendez-les, c'est difficile
puisque je viens de vous exprimer
exactement l'inverse et je me dis qu'il
faudrait évoluer, échanger et et
regarder son époque. Je pense que c'est
une question d'habitude, c'est une
question de de facilité aussi. On le
voit très bien, les Américains savent
très bien ce qu'ils font. On nous dit
Joe Biden, ah oui, John Carry l'autre
jour est intervenu en disant Joe Biden
ou en gros, il est un peu sénil, il a
pas vu non euh le la suppression,
l'arrêt du contrat d'armement avec
l'Australie, c'est America first. C'est
exactement ce que disait Trump. Sauf que
Trump, il avait l'honnêteté de le dire à
la face des gens. Il le faisait pas en
lousd. Il disait il disait les choses de
façon outrancière. Mais au moins, on
savait où on était. Obama était pareil
avant. Obama qui avec le sourire, avec
le charme, avec le Non mais bien sûr. Et
Obama a commencé d'abord d'ailleurs
Obama n'oublions jamais pourquoi Barack
Obama a été élu. Il a été élu sur une
plateforme anti-guerre contre les
guerres.
Il a balancé je sais pas combien de
millions de d'obus.
Oui. Non, il a pas balancé des millions
d'obus, il a dronné des milliers de
djihadistes. C'est lui qui en a tué le
plus. Oui, parce que il s'est relayé sur
ces ces ces armes-là, sur les forces
spéciales, l'élimination de Ben Laden.
Non, mais c'est c'est un c'est
important. Pourquoi il l'a fait ? Pour
ne pas avoir à faire des déploiements.
Obama n'est pas allé en Syrie non plus.
Il a regretté être allé en Libye. Donc
donc déjà, on est dans l'attitude qu'on
les États-Unis. Comme dirait les
États-Unis, de tout temps, ils ont
préservé leurs intérêts. Mais avant, on
était dans un espèce de démocratisme
messianique de guerre comment sans fin
en Irak, en Afghanistan, ça a duré 20
ans en Afghanistan, ça a duré 12 ans en
Irak. usante ruineuses sur lesquelles
les Américains se sont cassés les dents.
Et je vous faisais la le parallèle avec
la Nouvelle- Orléance, c'est qu'à un
moment les Américains sont rendus compte
qu'on on professie ailleurs et alors
qu'on était pas capable de s'occuper des
des Américains. Et ça c'était aussi un
argument utilisé par Trump, la les
déclassés de la mondialisation, les mecs
qui voyaient les usines partir en Chine,
Apple et cetera et cetera ou à
l'étranger et qui se retrouvaient sans
sans comment sans boulot. euh alors
qu'ils avaient pendant euh toute leur
vie travaillé honnêtement et ça avait
été des bons Américains. C'est comme ça
que Trump a gagné, hein. C'est c'est des
choses importantes parce que euh il y a
eu des phénomènes aussi similaires en
France. Mais pour tout tout ça pour dire
que ça fait trois mandats que l'Amérique
est sur le repli, que l'Amérique est sur
le retour des boys à la maison, qu'elle
est sur le redéploiement vers l'extrême
Orient parce que son objectif et et son
adversaire principal c'est la Chine
aujourd'hui et que nous on n' pas
compris qu'on devait on a une très très
bonne armée. Moi, j'ai fait un nombre de
de comment de sujets avec Barcan comment
sur j'ai accompagné la Légion, j'ai
accompagné les forces spéciales, j'ai
accompagné les commandau parachutistes à
Barcan. On a une armée si ça c'est
l'armée, c'est la pointe de diamant.
Les légionnaires, c'est la pointe de
diamant. Les marçoins c'est la pointe de
diamant. Les forces spéciales, c'est la
pointe de diamant. Et ce que je veux
vous dire, c'est que c'est des exemples
que je donne, c'est qu'on a une armée
euh qui est euh entraînée, qui vient de
passer effectivement 8 ans au SEL. S'il
y a un point positif, c'est qu'elle est
super entraînée, qu'on a une très bonne
armée, des capacités de déploiement à
l'étranger. Je pense à l'opération
Hamilton, même si les fondements de
cette opération m'ont pas toujours paru
douteux, mais bon, l'opération Hamilton
en Syrie, c'est une projection de nos
avions depuis la métropole. Enfin bref,
il y a quand même en France des
capacités euh je dirais militaires
considérables et on a une armée qui est
capable de faire l'évacuation euh
l'évacuation de Kaboule, elle a été
impeccablement réalisée par notre armée
de l'air et et donc moi, je je ne
critique pas l'armée française, je mais
en revanche aujourd'hui forcé de
constater que il faut que nous français
on voit nos intérêts et qu'on arrête
d'être à la remorque. Je sais pas, vous
voulez me demander de encore de me
mettre à la à la place du K d'Osé ? Je
pense que c'est des habitudes,
pas de vous mettre à la place.
Non, mais je pense que c'est des
habitudes. Ce sont des habitudes liées à
l'histoire, parfois lié à des cultures
familiales de Non, mais si de mon mon
grand-père a servi machin, a été proche
des Américains ou je dis pas que je je
Oui, oui, aussi. ou de l'intérêt aussi.
Mais je vais pas vous dire du mal euh
comment absolu des Américains. J'ai deux
enfants moi qui habitent aux États-Unis.
Euh ma première épouse était américaine
et j'ai une fille qui a eu et un fils
qui est qui travaille euh en Californie.
Donc euh
vous parlez anglais.
Oui, très bien. Oui. Oui, c'est ma c'est
je connais par cœur la mairie. J'ai a
passé euh presque comment 6 ans, je
passé plus de 6 ans comme correspondant
de match. Je l'ai sillonné en long, en
large et en travers. C'est un pays que
j'adore. Mais aujourd'hui, ce pays-là se
comporte avec ses alliés. euh comme des
des paillassons. Voilà,
ça a toujours été le cas.
Oui, mais on a toujours du mal à à le
comprendre et peut-être temps que que
maintenant que le monde qu'on émergé,
vous savez le la diplomatie en comment
dans les affaires étrangères, le vide ça
n'existe pas. Les Américains partent
d'un endroit, il y a une autre puissance
qui arrive. Euh en Afghanistan, on en
voit au moins trois qui sont à à la
manœuvre. la Chine, euh la Russie,
l'Iran, euh Pakistan, ça c'est plus
traditionnel. Voilà. Mais c'estes ces
ces ces puissances-là, elles ont quel
avantage ? Vous allez me dire, je vais
je vais être un peu sévère avec la
démocratie, c'est que c'est pas des pays
démocrates. Donc du coup, qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? La Russie euh
c'est un pays où depuis 20 ans, on a la
même politique, les mêmes personnes. La
Chine pareil et l'Iran globalement les
mêmes puisqu'on sait que c'est Raménie
derrière. Donc euh nous on a le défaut
des démocraties, c'est-à-dire que ça
change toutes les 5 ans. C'est une
richesse aussi, c'est l'alternance. Mais
au niveau de la politique, au niveau de
la définition de la politique d'une
administration, c'est extrêmement dur de
garder euh une conduite linéaire et au
niveau des négociations qu'on peut avoir
avec les divers groupes qui posent
problèmes dans le monde, en particulier
les talibans, c'est sûr que quand on a
le même interlocuteur depuis des années,
c'est plus facile. Bon voilà, c'est la
réalité et c'est l'avantage qu'on ces
pays
que comme les appelle Emmanuel Macron
illibéraux. Voilà. Mais euh mais mais en
tout cas euh moi ce que je veux dire, je
pense que ce qui se passe c'est qu'il y
a une habitude de la relation atlantique
euh qui est fortement euh ancré euh chez
nos diplomates, qui est fortement ancré
dans une partie de la classe politique
et qu'aujourd'hui face à l'émergence de
ces nouvelles puissances et si on veut
compter, si la France veut revenir sur
le premier plan ou en tout cas être
cette puissance médiane comme dit
Dominique de Villepin qui qui apporte
des solutions
qui apporte j'aime bien cette idée de de
la puissance qui peut intervenir entre
deux et et et améliorer les choses. La
France n'est plus du tout ça. Elle a
beaucoup perdu de carte. La guerre
syrienne a été une catastrophe. On est
rayé de la carte. Résumé trivial. Ouai.
Notre parole diplomatique en Afrique,
c'est terminé. He
oui.
Puis ça devient même dangereux pour les
Français.
Mais mais c'est terrible.
Pour résumer ça trivialement, faut
arrêter la lèche, hein. Faut retrouver
un petit peu notre courage.
Surtout que les Américains ne le
demandent pas. Quand ils sentent qu'on
est un peu vexé, vous savez ce qu'ils
font ? Ils nous ont fait le coup de
Blinken. J'appelle ça le coup de
Blinken. Pourquoi ? Parce que Blinken,
il a vécu à Paris. Blinken, il parle
impeccablement le français. il va
discuter avec Adsophil Pix que nous on
le propose on leur propose des
vo nous avons compris effectivement en
utilisant ces termes et cetera que cette
relation entre la France et les
États-Unis était tellement ancienne
qu'elle avait besoin d'être voilà bon
ils nous ont fait le coup de la
faillette le coup du débarquement
trivialement on dit quoi on dit se la
ferm avec un papier de soi c'est ça
et c'est un petit peu ça je il y a plein
de formules possibles et colorées pour
décrire ce ce sentiment
à l'amérie.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait nous ? On a on a
ramené nos deux ambassadeurs et ensuite
Ah oui, nous attendons des actes. Est-ce
qu'on s'est roulé Est-ce qu'on est-ce
qu'on s'est roulé sur la table avec
maman qui nous regardait ?
Euh
non,
je sais pas. Je je je suis
faud demander à Brigitte.
Oui.
Euh on arrive bien
on va rentrer dans la sphère intime là.
Oui. Oui. D'ailleurs, elle a bien du
courage cette damel.
Euh on arrive bientôt à la fin.
On va prendre quelques questions
internet. H
est-ce que avant de prendre les
questions internet, est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on discute d'un truc en
particulier ?
Euh d'un truc en particulier, j'aimerais
bien qu'on discute. Non, on a fait quand
même le tour de beaucoup de choses. Non,
on a même pas effleuré le
Non, non, mais on peut euh
Moi, j'ai parlé de de mes confrères,
j'ai parlé de ce ceux que j'admire, j'ai
parlé de
euh Vous
n'avez pas trouvé encore comment nous
décrire cette petite angoisse quand vous
êtes sur un théâtre d'opération pour
reprendre les mots d'un copain qui est
reporter de guerre, qui dormait avec des
cadavres,
qui a pris 25 kg parce que ça l'a
traumatisé. Il m'a dit un jour, c'est
comme si vous sentiez la main froide de
la mort vous attraper la moelle épinière
à la base de votre crâne.
H mais ça je dis je ressentirai pas les
choses comme ça quand quand il arrive un
truc sur ces terrains. Euh je dirais
qu'il y a il y a le temps, il y a une
angoisse oui qui peut monter. Puis
après, il y a une espèce d'explosion
d'adrénaline euh qui fait queon n'est
pas forcément conscient de de ce qui se
passe et qu'ensuite c'est pour
postériorique qu'on se dit "Putain, là
on a vraiment eu chaud quoi." Euh
tu as fait une dépression ? Non, j'ai
j'ai pas fait de dépression, mais il
m'est arrivé de faire des rêves mais pas
euh euh en me en me réveillant euh euh
la nuit ou même en plein jour euh en
comment tout à coup en il y a il y a une
difficulté hein, je parlais de Mosou
tout à l'heure là.
Sursautez pas avec les balles
là. Non, ça ça les pétards. Oui, m'
m'embête le les les pétards du 14
juillet, le le Oui, ça me fait quelque
chose. Oui, oui. Et je suis obligé de
rien dire parce que c'est bah parce que
je vais pas dire arrêter alors que les
gens sont joyeux. Et
vous avez pas envie de leur dire bande
de connard, vous rendez pas compte ce
qui se passe de l'autre côté du monde et
c'est vos impôts qui payent cette merde
?
Euh, c'est un résumé un peu synthétique
là de
pas la vérité.
Les impôts payent Oui, payent les armes
qu'on vend. On est le troisème vendeur
d'armes au monde. Vous savez, je vais
vous dire un truc. Euh, je pense très
sincèrement que s'il y avait pas ce
marché des armes, il y aurait très peu
de problèmes finalement parce que les
ennemis euh qui euh qui s'affrontent,
les les communautés, les machins et
cetera, les clans euh bah seraient bien
obligé de dialoguer puisqu'ils
pourraient pas se tuer. C'est très naïf
hein ce que je dis. Non, vous avez pas
lu clos en fait. Mais vous pensez qu'il
trouverait d'autres armes et qui se
quand même ? Oui, très bien.
Très bien.
Oui.
La politique, la guerre c'est quoi ? La
guerre, la guerre c'est c'est le
prolongement de la politique par
d'autres monna.
Est-ce que là je rebondis sur cette
question internet qui qui d'ailleurs
tombe à point si j'arrive à la retrouver
au milieu des lignes ? Euh je vais la
résumer. Ah si. En tant que journaliste
de guerre, ayant une vision des plus
concrètes de l'état du monde, a-t-il
encore confiance dans le monde politique
? S'engagerait-il ?
Euh,
je peux répéter la question s'il vous
plaît Non, non, c'est une bonne
question. Non, non, c'est bien. J'ai euh
est-ce que je m'engagerai euh il
faudrait que ça ça corresponde à une
autre phase de ma vie que je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas terminé cette phase- là du
reportage. Ça, j'en suis intimement
persuadé. Euh je l'ai pas terminé à
cause de peut-être euh j'aurais pu la
terminer euh j'aurais pu être un
directeur adjoint de Paris match restant
dans les bureaux. Et
35000 boules par mois.
Non, pas 35000 et mais
Non, pas 45000 non plus.
65000 ?
Non, je suis arrivé à une époque où ça
payait plus. J'ai pas eu de bol.
Ça paye toujours bien la presse à ce
niveau-là ? Non,
non, ça paye pas. Non, je sais que vous
essayez de me cuisiner là-dessus.
L'argent est quelque chose qui doit vous
quand ça commence à payer, c'est combien
? Non, mais il y a pas de de on fait pas
ce métier pour ça. Voilà, terminé. Mais
euh le le le Non, mais que ce que ce que
je veux dire, c'est que euh est-ce que
je pourrais m'engager ? C'est ça la la
question. Euh c'est ça la question. Euh
avec ce que j'ai vu, avec ce que j'ai je
trouve euh les hommes politiques euh
je trouve qu'and
parfois c'est euh on voit quand
quelqu'un connaît un pays ou quand
quelqu'un l'a étudié. Alors, il y a ceux
qui ont été présidents des cercles
d'amitié franco machin, donc ils sont
allés dans le pays et cetera.
C'est un peu bullshit pour découvrir un
pays.
Bah oui, puisque c'est on y
mais mais nous on y voit on voit aussi
une forme distordue quoi. On voit une
forme de guerre, on voit pas forcément
le pays dans la paix. Alors, quand on
l'a vu sur plusieurs euh plusieurs
années, euh oui, on peut voir des
changements et peut dire voilà, on
connaît bien le pays, mais je trouve par
exemple sur la la question des des
djihadistes euh ou la question de ces
mouvements qui sont apparus chez nous
euh de façon complètement euh
surprenante quoi, les les les on s'est
aperçu que dans le quartier d'à côté,
bah il y avait des types qui étaient
partis le djihad en Syrie et cetera. Ça
a été un phénomène totalement nouveau et
je trouve que par rapport à ça, on a une
classe politique qui était quand même
pas armée intellectuellement euh qui
n'avait pas étudié, qui connaissait pas
l'islam tout simplement. Bon, ça veut
pas dire que on est obligé de devenir un
exégète dans comme phonétique du Coran,
mais on peut quand même avoir des bases,
on peut quand même s'informer et je suis
assez surpris parfois de voir le niveau
de d'un certain nombre d'hommes
politiques. Je pareil les histoires de
Taliban et l'Afghanistan, c'est très
complexe, mais justement cette
complexité, il faut s'y frotter avant
pour pouvoir avoir une opinion. pour
éviter de refaire la Libye.
Oui. Et la Libye, c'est un mélange
inconcentré d'intérêt de de comment de
voilà et on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec
toujours la même la même question. Euh
c'est bien d'abattre le dictateur.
Qu'est-ce qu'on met à la place ? Voilà,
je répète la question. En tant que
journaliste de guerre ayant une vision
des plus concrètes de l'état du monde,
a-t-il encore confiance dans le monde
politique ? S'engagerait-il ? Je je
pense qu'il y a des gens dans le monde
politique, il y a des gens honnêtes. Euh
euh je sais pas, il y a des gens qui
regardent les choses, je vous en prendre
un à gauche et un à droite pour être
au centre.
Non, euh il y a il y a aujourd'hui un
état de tension de la société qui fait
que euh c'est difficile de qui
les politiques honnêtes h
il y a il y a des
je vous vous prenez vous parlez des
candidats au présidentiel. Pour vous,
pour vous, il y a qui comme politique
honnête ?
Comme politique honnête,
je suis sympa. Je vous demande pas les
politiques malhonnêtes.
Euh
ouais, c'est euh
laissez-moi un peu réfléchir, je je
parlé mais Non, non, je je pense
dire vous avez beaucoup parlé, vous
trouvez pas parce que c'est difficile de
trouver un politique honnête. Non, non,
mais j'essaie de j'essaie de trouver. Je
je sais qu' je sais qu'il y en a.
Cherchez, cherchez cherchez.
Ouais. Je je sais que
euh Non mais on est tellement dans la
com, on est tellement dans la euh
c'est euh
mais je pense que vous m'avez je j'en
vois pas en fait pas là. Voilà
un de droite qui est pas mal là qui
s'est battu pour la faire stom qui qui
est péchu.
David Lissnard.
Non
je pense que David Lissenard est un mec
honnête.
Je peux vous aider alors ?
Voilà.
Non mais je pense maintenant il est
maire de Cann. Est-ce qu'il a un destin
national ? J'en sais rien. Mais
peut-être qu'il est bon que pour être
maire de Canne. Voilà. Mais je pense que
c'est quelqu'un qui a pas voilà trop de
de d'arrière-pensé ni de casserole ni de
voilà dans une zone où il y a beaucoup
de casserole et de
un peu comme chez les journalistes.
Non je parle des paqu du paca. Le paca.
Voilà.
Le panier de crab on dit.
Euh question internet question de cast.
Comment qualifie-t-il les retours de la
part de sa caste journalistique
française les anciens proches collègues
sur son actuelle activité chez RT France
depuis un mois ?
Euh collabo traître quoi d'autre ? J'ai
eu des des
oui des petites choses comme ça. Mais
pas tant je me suis moins euh moins fait
comment dire me suis moins pris de de du
plomb que mon collègue Frédéric Tadéi
quand il est arrivé quoi. Euh
il a su les plâtres. Bah oui, mais euh
c'était dégueulasse d'ailleurs.
Oui. Oui, mais c'est dégueulasse. Mais
plutôt que de critiquer la présence d'un
journaliste sur une chaîne, euh la
question faudrait qu'il faudrait que ces
gens-là se posent, c'est pourquoi leurs
médias mainstream si on va dire sont de
moins en moins euh comment dire suivis ?
C'est ça le problème. Et pourquoi on est
là dans un truc qui s'appelle Tinker
Viiew ?
Finalement, on arrive à parler librement
sans avec quand même un interview qui
vous qui vous coupe quand même pas mal.
Mais mais
te mar pas trop parce que je t'ai pas
encore pété les dents.
Mais ça c'est le rugby, c'est après et
c'est après la bière. Mais non, pourquoi
pourquoi on en est là ? C'est parce que
le reste ne fonctionne pas et qu'il y a
plus cette il y a plus de confiance.
Donc ils ont beau dire ah bah oui, tu
vas travailler chez les Russes traiter
mourir de rire. il ils sont en train de
se polariser. Vous connaissez le budget
de fonctionnement de votre chaîne ?
Vous avez fait le pédigré de votre
chaîne ?
J'ai fait le pédigré mais les affaires
euh ils ont un budget de fonctionnement
qui doit être 1/5e de la majeure partie
des chaînes françaises.
Oui.
Ils se font emmerder par ça.
Oui. Oui.
Par 1/5 du budget. Ça mourir de rire.
Vous savez quand quand j'étais à match,
j'ai connu ça aussi. On appelle ça, nous
on appelait ça les bœufs carottes de la
profession. C'est comme chez les flics,
c'estàdire les mecs qui viennent remuer
le truc, qui t'ont trouvé un machin et
qui vont faire un édito.
Ah ben oui, mais il y en a c'est c'est
c'est voilà ces paroles d'évangile. Ils
ont trouvé que dans l'article, tu as
fait un et hop, ils en tirent une
conclusion. Il y a des spécialistes
là-dedans euh association
mais mais nous euh bon j'ai vu quelque
chose quelques euh je je sais que j'ai
eu des des une altercation d'ailleurs
intéressante avec le l'ancien l'ancien
ambassadeur de France à Washington
Gérard Aro il y a pas longtemps
c'était Jacques Andréani c'est ça ?
Ouais. Donc Aold qui lui était
celui qui bosse pour la firme qui fait
des écoutes, c'est ça ?
Bon, je voilà mais c'était pas
qui qui a juste signé pour faire un peu
de speech c'est ça
c'est voilà
no la société
no voilà Pegasus
le truc qui a écouté c de nos ministres
tout à fait
je crois que cette nétait pas
il y a pas il y avait pas une enquête
sur lui ou je sais pas quoi un
signalement
absolument et je le laisse gérer ça
c'était pas sur ce sujet-là notre
altercation notre altercation non je je
vais pas le le c'était c'était plus
feutré et puis il y avait un dialogue
Euh moi j'ai commencé, j'avais fait un
tweet justement en disant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait encore dans l'OTAN
après un peu sous le coup de la colère
avec le l'histoire des sous-marins parce
que l'histoire des sous-marins, je vous
ai parlé de mon papa pour commencer mais
moi j'ai une copine qui travaille pour
Naval Group, j'ai comment des gens qui
voilà qui sont employés de de en
Normandie.
Les sous-marinés sont top. Mais oui, non
seulement les sous-marinés sont top,
mais là-bas, vous avez plus de 10000
personnes qui travaillent pour ce
groupe. Ils ont ouvert les vannes de
l'emploi en Normandie dans dans la
Manche. Grâce à ce contrat, il y avait
des Australiens qui ont commencé à vivre
à Cherbourg, à s'installer à Cherbourg.
Donc c'était quelque chose qui était en
cours. C'est pas nouveau. C'est pas
comme si disait le contrat il a été
signé. Ah on arrête parce queil y a
Biden. Non, il y avait déjà eu il y a
des gens qui ont vécu en Australie, des
gens de Cherbourg et qui sont revenus.
C'est une réalité. Euh moi j'aime j'aime
les réalités en fait si vous voulez. Moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est surtout les
gens euh vous l'avez compris et et et
quand quand je pense contrat comme ça,
j'ai la j'ai la chance d'avoir une maman
qui habite à Cherbourg et et je connais
c'est cette réalité-là et d'avoir un
papa qui a fait les qui a fabriqué les
qui qui a euh en tout cas euh participé
de l'aventure des sous-marins français.
Et donc ça me voilà. Donc je fais ce
tweet et là euh le notre ambassadeur,
notre ex-ambassadeur me dit "Oui, nous
n'avons jamais quitté l'OTAN, ce qui est
vrai. Nous avons quitté simplement bon
une petite remontrance et voilà et à un
moment je lui propose, je lui dis
puisque tout est c'est très intéressant
la discussion qu'on a, venez sur RT,
venez en parler avec moi sur RT."
Tu cherches, tu cherches ?
Non. et il me répond "Je n'irai pas
commenter sur une chaîne payée parle et
cetera." Et là, je lui réponds une
chose. Je lui dis "Vous êtes moi je suis
journaliste, vous vous êtes diplomate.
C'est pas le job d'un diplomate. C'est
pas dans l'ADN d'aller parler à ses
adversaires." Et là, il m'a pas répondu.
Voilà. Mais c'est vrai, la diplomatie,
c'est l'art de parler aux gens qui ont
du sens sur les mains. Sinon, on fait
des écoles de moral, si ça nous plaît
pas, on fait autre chose. Mais c'est
d'aller se confronter, d'aller porter
c'est John Kry, Serge Lavrov au moment
de la bataille d'Aleppe qui passent des
discussions interminables pour faire en
sorte que leur poulins sur le terrain
arrêtent de de de de
s'entretuer.
C'est un cancer la moraline dans
Mais c'est terrible. C'est venu avec
Laurent Fabius en en diplomatie en
France. ça est devenu à partir du moment
où à partir du moment où ce ce ministère
de de ce ministre a commencé à voilà,
c'était et et avec ça, on a perdu toutes
les cartes parce que je veux dire, on ne
peut pas faire de la morale en
permanence, on peut pas, il faut
regarder les choses telles qu'elles
sont. Le monde il est lait, le monde il
est fait de gens qui voilà qui qui sont
ennemis les uns les autres. Il faut le
prendre comme il est. On peut pas
projeter sur lui une fantasmagorie de ce
qu'on voudrait qu'il soit. C'est pas
possible. et surtout quand on est dans
ces positions-là. Et là, je disais voilà
cet ambassadeur, je rappelais à cet
ambassadeur que le rôle de la diplomatie
précisément c'est d'aller parler à ses
adversaires. Donc venez sur RT si vous
considérez qu' RT, ce qui est pas le cas
parce que RT c'est une chaîne où il y a
des gens qui viennent, j'étais avec le
général Trincamp hier à parler de
l'Afghanistan et avec un un comment un
Afghan de l'exil qui était en Skype. Où
est la la donne russe là-dedans ? Où est
où est la pression ? Où est la
propagande ? Je je vois pas. Euh donc il
y a il y a des gens qui acceptent de
venir mais il y a toujours cette cette
espèce de de jugement à for à priori euh
sur cette chaîne. Euh jugement qui est
qui me semble être moins employé quand
on parle d'Algesra euh qui pourtant est
payé par les l'État du Qatar. La BBC est
payée par l'Angleterre et euh France 24
est payée par l'État français. Donc
voilà. Euh donc il y a euh on peut
critiquer la Russie, on peut critiquer
Poutine, mais la la l'ADN de la de la
chaîne en France, elle est française et
la plupart des gens avec qui je côtoie
d'ailleurs une une rédaction d'une
diversité euh ethnique, euh background
et cetera comme j'ai jamais vu ailleurs
parce que les autres journalistes
français sont très bien mais vous
regardez la représentativité
de leur rédaction et et la diversité
dans leur rédaction, il y a quand même
des choses à revoir.
Je vous sens très fier d'avoir sorti ça.
Je suis pas fier. Je j'ai toujours
trouvé que pendant des années, on nous
fait des leçons de morale sur euh euh le
fait que euh la France est raciste et
cetera et cetera. Et puis en réalité euh
euh
toujours le cas.
Voilà.
Un autre sujet, petite question
internet.
Ouais.
Alors Macron qui engueule mal Bruno au
Liban, il en pense quoi ? Un politique
engueulé par un journaliste. Un
politique engueule un journaliste et Gat
qui se défend qui défend Sarco entre
parenthèse un journaliste défend un
politique. Fermez la parenthèse.
Moi je crois que dans les deux cas alors
sur le je commenterai pas le le le
l'attitude d'Herve Gatot vis-à-vis de
Nicolas Sarkozi, c'est pas je je
mais chacun en pense ce qu'il veut. Moi,
en revanche, oui, euh de faire une leçon
à à un journaliste parce que en effet,
il a décrypté et c'est son rôle euh les
comment les arcanes des négociations euh
et de l'intervention en fait du
gouvernement français auprès du du
gouvernement libanais pour essayer de
euh là, oui, il y a quelque chose de euh
de choquant. Euh je pense,
je me base toujours, j'ai dit beaucoup
de mal des États-Unis aujourd'hui, mais
il me semble qu'aux États-Unis, ce genre
de choses n'existe pas.
Du mal
Ouais, j'ai dit du mal. J'ai dit qu'en
tout cas, il fallait qu'on qu'on revoit
notre Non, mais si si je je enfin, j'ai
critiqué les États-Unis, j'ai été
critique. Ce que je veux dire, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
alors alors critique, ça veut dire faire
du mal.
Non, non, non. Je pense que c'est
clairvoyant ce que j'ai dit. Je le
retire pas mais c'est juste une
expression. C'est pour dire que je vais
dire quelque chose de positif sur les
États-Unis, c'est que je pense que euh
même s'il y a toujours des moyens de
pression, comme vous dites, même s'il y
a toujours des euh des comment des
censures et des autocensures de la part
des journalistes, il me semble qu'aux
États-Unis la presse se défend mieux.
Euh la presse agit si il y a quand même
des critères euh voilà de de euh et euh
et des choses à ne pas faire notamment
dans la dans la collusion enfin dans le
dans le dans le rapport entre le
politique et et la presse. Jamais
critiqué la guerre, c'est ça ?
Non, il y a des il y a plein de médias
aux États-Unis qui ont critiqué la
guerre.
Lesquel ? euh bah Rolling Stone euh euh
même des médias comme USA Today, même
quand quand la guerre a commencé
évidemment à tourner euh à euh au
désavantage de l'armée américaine, c'est
sûr que c'était plus facile de la
critiquer. Mais même, il y a toujours eu
euh Moi, je me souviens du New York
Times, je je je j'avais un je les voyais
à Bagdad à l'époque, on on faisait des
des euh on allait souvent avec les
soldats américains, ils avaient des
critères extrêmement précis. Euh par
exemple euh pendant la la mort de Ben
Laden. La mort de Ben Laden. Euh
l'exécution.
Euh oui, enfin il s'est défendu hein. Et
euh
une femme, c'est ça ? H
Oui, enfin il y avait une femme dans la
pièce. Voilà. Ensuite, son fils, un de
ses fils, a tiré sur les Nevicils, donc
quand ils ont monté l'escalier au
dernier étage. Et le problème qui s'est
posé, c'est qu'il y a eu une narration
qui a été donnée officiellement
et bien
bien malin serait celui qui qui serait
capable de dire puisque on est dans dans
le JSOC donc Joint Special Operation
Command les Navicil c'est donc les
forces spécial donc il y a rien qui
filtre simplement la narration qui a été
faite par Obama et par un certain nombre
de de de d'acteurs qui ont été autorisés
à parler. Moi, j'avais rencontré le
l'amiral Mcraven qui a qui a monté
l'opération, qui m'a dit ce qu'il
pouvait m'en dire. Maintenant, est-ce
que tout était vrai ? J'en sais rien. Il
y a eu une chose qui a été importante,
ça été le traitement du corps de Ben
Laden. Le traitement du corps de Ben
Laden a été envoyé sur un porteavion,
voilà, et ensuite jeté à la mer.
Comment Léon Panela qui était le le
patron de la CIA a qui est resté comment
? paneta pardon et qui est resté très
longtemps le le le comment le
responsable du bureau de la CIA en
Arabie Saoudite a appelé les oulemas
pour demander comme Benaden était
saoudien si euh le fait bon il il il y a
donc il y a eu une une recherche de euh
du meilleur traitement possible pour le
corps de l'ennemi absolu. Bon, les
Saoudiens ont ont dit "OK" et donc ils
ont fait ce en revanche
à société de presse qui est la plus
vieille agence du monde à société de
presse immédiatement a demandé
qu'on rende publique les photos de Ben
Laden. Mort.
On l'avait fait pour Saddam Hussein, on
l'a fait pour Zarkai, on l'a fait pour
des grands terroristes.
Immédiatement d'ailleurs, Saddam Husen a
été montré pendu
d'ailleurs
et avant, il y a même eu une vidéo qui
est sortie et Zarkaoui, on l' retrouvé
au milieu des ruines après cette prix
Kaddafi aussi.
Kaddafi Zarkawioui après cette prix une
bombe de 500 kg sur la tronche. Voilà.
Bon donc les photos bien graphiques
quoi. Bien voilà
histoire de tuer dans l'œuf. Voilà,
c'est pas un nouvel
pour dire c'est bien lui et cetera. Ben
Laden niet
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'est-ce qu' a
fait AP ? Ils ont attaqué le
gouvernement américain.
Voilà Freedom of Information Act. Et
donc voilà,
il y a ça en France, le Freedomation.
Non, il y a pas ce ce Freedom of
Information Act justement. Il y a pas
cette capacité qui a la presse de se
mobiliser euh pour euh pour pouvoir
avoir des accès pour pouvoir C'est c
c'est extrêmement compliqué. Parce que
parce que en France, on a une presse
déloppée avec des des journalistes
sédés, des salles de rédaction euh sans
sans trop de courage.
Euh il y a il y a peut-être de ça, il y
a peut-être une collusion plus
importante, je pense, entre les
journalistes et le monde politique,
hein, on le voit. et même d'ailleurs des
futurs candidats qui sont d'anciens
journalistes hein euh je sais pas pas
citer Éric Zemour mais bon euh des gens
qui s'échappent de la sphère médiatique
pour devenir politique. C'est pour ça
que il y avait une des questions tout à
l'heure. Est-ce que vous voulez vous
engager dans quel dans quel voilà j'ai
des convictions certes. Oui oui j'ai des
convictions.
Vous votez quoi ? Moi, je suis je suis
je suis je suis je suis de droite. Moi,
je suis euh je suis un garçon de droite.
Euh mais euh j'ai été euh euh comment
dire euh
je je le le voyez je pensais au je
pensais que vous alliez me poser la
question sur Zemour. Euh
donc vous voulez que vous vous pose
cette question ? Non, je veux pas que
vous la posiez, mais je pense que c'est
plus essentiel que de dire pour qui je
vais voter. Le la la question de Zemour
et la question de l'émergence de Zemour
m'intéresse plus que le personnage
lui-même. Personnage, j'ai fait ses
émissions, j'ai été accepté à l'époque,
enfin à l'époque, on me critiquait aussi
en disant "Mais comment tu vas sur face
à l'info et cetera ? Euh tu vas parler à
Zemmour
Non, je je oui, j'y suis allé, j'y fais
une vingtaine de fois l'émission et
mais en revanche, ce que je veux dire,
c'est que dans ce dans ce phénomène là,
il y a tout à coup quelque chose qui
échappe au contrôle. On est d'accord ?
Parlait du contrôle tout à l'heure, des
choses installées, de de l'accès et
cetera, du voilà. Là, tout à coup, on a
un type
et le parallèle avec Trump m'a toujours
paru absolument évident. pourrait le
faire aussi dans une moindre mesure avec
Boris Johnson avec son idée de Brexit
avec euh voilà ce qui est très
intéressant chez ces personnages-là,
très opportunistes, qui arrive à un
moment de l'histoire, c'est que tout à
coup bam, il rentre en en il tape dans
une corde dans une corde qui va
raisonner
à travers le la France. Euh
la corde, c'est quoi ? C'est c'est la
presse française. Non, c'est pas la
presse française. Ça se fait au-delà de
la presse française. Vous parlez de la
presse française obsolète, c'est
justement précisément parce qu'elle est
pas capable de de de déterminer ces ces
phénomènes là. Et pour ce qui est de
Trump, je peut-être je je me me me jeter
des fleurs, mais en dehors de moi et
André Berkov, on était les deux seuls à
avoir dit attention en novembre 2016
Trump a a moyen de l'emporter. Je me
souviens à l'époque Guillaume Duran, on
était sur Radio classique tous les deux.
Mais c'est pas possible, vous voyez bien
les sondages. Hillary Clinton n naana et
Guillaume m'a appelé après pour me dire
"Tu avais raison, toi et André vous êtes
les deux seuls."
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des charniers
de Timoara ? Là
là c'est c'est ça remonte. J'étais pas
encore reporter à l'époque. La mise en
scène, c'est ça de l'exécution de
Chachescou du couple.
Non, c'est les corps qui ont été sortis
de la mort pour montrer que
Oui, ben ça ça fait partie c'est comme
les les fameuses couveuses couettes
l'ont de l'ambassadeur qui parlait
d'ailleurs
au couette.
C'est celle qui parle avec les larmes
très très chaudes.
Oui oui oui, c'est ça. Oui, on a trouvé
ensuite c'était une mise en scène mais
c'est pas la première mise en scène qui
peuvent exister et qui provoquent
des armes de destruction massive.
Ça c'est la plus la plus grosse
escroquerie. Non mais regardez regardons
quand même les choses. Je veux dire, on
a parlé effectivement des crimes de
Bachard qui ont été largement mais
George Bouche
George Bouche qui a engagé son pays dans
une guerre sous des prétextes falaux
avec des fausses preuves avec des
dossiers bricolés que le brave Coline
Powell a vendu avec sa fiole le 13
février 2003 à la tribune de l'ONU. Moi
je l'ai interviewé Powel après il m'a
dit c'était le le the lowest point of my
career. Il m'a dit
il a surtout dit qu'il s'était fait
intoxiqué par les services de
renseignement de son compte
complètement. Mais tout tout ça ça a été
fabriqué. Donc on a fabriqué une guerre
qui n'a pas simplement déstabilisé
l'Irak, qui n'a pas simplement
livré ce pays dans une guerre civile
atroce qui a contaminé toute la région.
La boîte du pandor de pandor
la boîte de pandor du du djihadisme,
elle avait déjà été ouverte en
Afghanistan. euh avec Daesh. Daesh,
finalement quand on y réfléchit, c'est
la vengeance de Saddam Hussein. C'est
parce qu'on a pas su trouver la suite.
Mais même
cadre de ces mais ça des généraux, moi
j'ai j'ai une amitié avec le général
Petreus euh qui était qui était
l'intellectuel, le mec qu'on a appelé en
mode pompier pour rattraper cette guerre
qui partait qui allait nulle part.
Petreus avait dit déjà à l'époque, il
avait dit "Mais après Bagdad, qu'est-ce
qu'on fait ?" Voilà. Et c'était le même
la même question s'est posée après
Kaddafi, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Bah si, bah on va mettre un type, il
s'appelle Ahmad Shalabi, il a habité 30
ans aux États-Unis, on le fait revenir,
on le remet et tout va bien. En plus, il
est cheat, tout va bien. Bon, sauf que
ça se passe pas comme ça. Voilà,
on pourrait faire durer cette interview
pendant des heures, mais la
on pourrait parler des armées aussi
qu'on a essayé de former des armées
locales pendant des années à
l'occidental. Sauf que les types des
types qui obéissent à une logique de
tribu de clan ne comprennent pas qu'on
va leur mettre un colonel qui ne
connaissent pas. Vous voyez de la la
façon dont on a voulu former l'armée
afghane et l'armée iraakienne ont été
des erreurs absolues. Aujourd'hui en
Afrique, on a quand même un peu compris
avec nos forces spéciales parce qu' plus
intelligents et mieux équipés que les
autres, il fallait se baser sur un
commandant local qui avait une certaine
aura et que là on avait plus de
résultats quand on se basait sur ce
genre de mec. Saqu vous savez pourquoi
on arrive à faire ça ? Parce que quand
l'armée française arrive dans un
village, qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ?
Dire "Bonjour, elle enlève le casque."
Oui, bien sûr, bien sûr, bien sûr. Oui,
oui. Et
et la la France, comme nous, on n' pas
de pognon, on n' pas de pétrole, on a
des idées.
Oui.
Et on sait que un sourire coûte moins
cher qu'une balle. Ben,
je vous vois patriote. Bravo.
Est-ce que vous
vous aimez l'armée ? C'est pas que
j'aime l'armée, c'est je respecte les
femmes de ménage des politiques.
C'est toujours l'armée qui fait le
ménage.
Oui.
Qui va rattraper les merdes de machin.
Ça, j'ai pas arrêté de le dire toute ma
carrière. Des pauvres types qui enfin
des pauvres types non que quand ils
meurent, c'est dire "Putain, mais voilà
euh c'est eux à qui on demande le boulot
et c'est eux qui vivent avec la guerre
dans la tête." Après,
comment on dit bon gars en russe ? J'en
sais rien, je parle pas russe.
Vous avez trois livres
ni mail, je ne sais pas.
Vous avez euh un bon gars en russe, ça
se dit mal à diète.
Ah et euh vous avez trois livres à
conseiller euh
à notre communauté.
Trois livres sur les thématiques ou ou
n'importe quoi.
Ah bon ? C'est open bar.
Moi je je suis je disais toujours qu'on
perd jamais son temps si on relit le
vieil homme et la mère des Mingou.
Euh
ensuite
bah le
bouquin de
euh
Non mais il plutôt un je vais je vais
leur retrouver bah Clositz
que j'ai dans ma bibliothèque.
Non c'est pas facile.
Alors close quel livre de closez ?
Je l'ai dans ma bibliothèque pas sorti.
Il faut visualiser la couverture. C'est
le gros, le petit, le modèle de poche
qui qui rentre pas dans la poche.
Non non non, c'est un gros. C'est un
vieux que j'ai dans la bibliothèque et
que j'ai déjà utilisé.
Ça commence par deux.
Oui, c'est de la guerre ou voilà. Voilà.
Ouais. Non non, ça c'est c'est limpide.
Et puis si on veut comprendre les
C'est limpide.
Si si. Si on veut comprendre les
logiques de contreinsurrection,
il
faut se les farcir quand même.
Passionnant. Faut lire Gal. euh traduit
par Petréus justement enfin traduit donc
Petreus a fait la la traduction en
français parce que ce qui est hyper
intéressant du bouquin
comment
le nom du bouquin
euh comment contre insurrection théorie
et principes
et donc Galula, le colonel Galula qui
est un type qui a eu une une
voilà c'est ça fait partie des grands
gâchis de l'armée française.
Il arrive dans le Jebel
algérien, le commandant
à qui il succède, il est capitaine.
L'insurrection du FLN est à son plus
haut plus haut stade. Guula arrive,
quand il part, il y a plus il y a plus
d'insurrection. C'est avant les tortures
dans les pots de porc ou des des grilles
comme ça ou
ça se fait en parallèle mais pas dans
son coin. Le type qui le qui lui succède
sera tué par l'insurrection. Euh Guelula
euh il a ce ce qui est intéressant de
dans Guula, c'est je ce que c'est pour
ça que je je dis je dis que le livre est
est je le conseille parce que c'est un
livre pratique, c'est un livre et alors
pour que ceux qui se passionnent encore
plus de sur l'Afghanistan, euh
moi c'est un livre que alors il est très
difficile à trouver, il s'appelle il il
a été traduit en anglais parce qu'au
départ il été écrit en russe et il
s'appelle The Bear went Over the
Mountain. En français, ça donne
ça donne l'ours à traversé la montagne.
raconte l'expérience des Russes un soir
de Noël qui ont envahi l'Afghanistan et
ce sont tous les recueils faits par la
Fruns, c'est-à-dire l'armée la
l'accadémie militaire soviétique à
l'époque qui a compilé les recueils le
retex du terrain et elle a pas fait que
The Bear went over the mountain, elle a
fait aussi The other side of the
mountain, c'est-à-dire l'autre côté de
la montagne, la version des mjahidines.
Donc quand vous lisez ces deux bouquins,
vous avez sur la même bataille un côté
et l'autre. Les Américains ont attendu
15 ans avant de faire traduire ce livre,
mais ils sont arrivés dans une période
de contre-insurrection et on leur a dit,
"Faut vraiment que vous lisiez ça parce
que vous allez trouver le même village,
vous allez trouver les Russes
accompagnés par une armée afghane fait
de br fait de briqu et de broc et vous
allez retrouver exactement ce que vous
vivez aujourd'hui." Et et et voilà. Donc
ça ça fait partie c'est c'est si sur les
les les expériences militaires. Gal
c'est ces deux ces deux bouquins, on les
trouve peut-être sur Amazon. En tout cas
moi c'était des officiers américains qui
me les avaient qui me les avaient passé
et puis ouaising parce queinguay quoi.
Vous avez vous avez lu un bouquin sur
les techniques de contre-insurrection.
H
les gilets jaunes. La façon dont ça a
été tabassé dans la rue et du clé.
On sent que ça c'est c'est dans les
tripes chez vous. Non. Ah bah vous
savez, vous savez, moi j'ai j'ai vu j'ai
vu des j'ai vu des théâtres d'opération
avec des photos bien cracas.
Je vais vous dire par rapport à une
question, s'il y a des gens qui nous
suivent depuis le début, vous m'avez
posé une question à laquelle j'ai pas
répondu. Avaller des couleuvres. Ouais,
j'en ai avalé une à propos des gilets
jaunes. Je vais vous expliquer très bien
pourquoi. Après, on
je trouve qu'on a
très peu couvert et ça pour des raisons
euh lié à une tendance, une orientation,
le pouvoir et cetera. ce que j'appelle
les gilets jaunes des ronds-points
qui était parce que moi je suis allé les
voir un jour, je partais passais du côté
des vreux, mec me bloque, il pleut puis
je vois une femme avec son gosse.
Il y avait un type qui avait dû amener
un frigo, ils avaient commencé à faire
cramer des planches dans la pluie. Euh
je me suis arrêté puis j'ai été j'ai été
leur parler enfin je et
je me suis dit qu'en fait j'ai compris
qu'en fait une partie de la classe
moyenne française euh avait glissé dans
la pauvreté et que
le phénomène je l'ai décrit pour les
États-Unis mais le problème c'est pas
que cette classe elle glisse dans la
pauvreté c'est que c'est des gens qui
toute leur vie ont payé leurs amendes
exactement payé leurs impôts, ont
respecté les limitations de vitesse, on
fait la la comment
la la carte grise tous les ans de leur
enfin
la cheville ouvrière de la France,
tout impeccable. Et là, le 11 du mois,
il y a plus rien. Voilà. Et ça ce alors
ça avait été décrit dans très bon
bouquin aussi le la France périphérique
euh qu'on a vu dans qu'on voit
concrètement dans certains certaines
villes. Moi je par j'ai oublié le nom.
Euh mais le c'est un sociologue
qui qui a écrit ça la la France
périphérique. France périphérique très
important qui explique par exemple
j'évoqué Cherbourg mais Cherbourg c'est
une ville qui s'est vidée de sa
substance. Il y avait une rue, je vous
je donne un exemple hein, une rue qui
s'appelait la rue de la soif où tous les
marins allaient quand la marine
nationale était dans le coin. Euh dans
cette dans cette rue aujourd'hui, il y a
plus un seul bar ouvert. Même les kebabs
ferment, voyez. Alors, quand il y a eu
le contrat Naval Group, évidemment, ça a
ramené du dynamisme, mais si vous
voulez, le le centre-ville a été
complètement vidé. Alors voilà, c'est ça
ce que j'appelle la France périphérique,
c'estàdire c'est c'est toutes ces
régions délaissées finalement qui qui
échappe à un mouvement national ou en
tout cas et et et sur les gilets jaunes,
j'ai toujours eu il faut jamais oublier
que les gilets jaunes, ils sont nés,
c'est une insurrection qui est née comme
les jaqueries au Moyen-âge parce que il
y a plus il y a soit de l'impôt, soit la
taxe des carburants. Et c'est comme ça
que que le mouvement est né. La
répression qui a eu lieu, je l' trouvé
oui fantastiquement violente de la part
de de l'État. On a senti même une
certaine fébrilité
je pense qui n'a été qui n'a pas été
analysé d'ailleurs à mon sens vraiment
profondément. C'eston a on n pas su dans
les ors noires de de ces de ces des
Champs-Élysées et cetera. Euh quel quel
a été qu'est-ce qui s'est vraiment passé
à l'Élysée ? Qu'est-ce qui s'est
vraiment passé au ministère de
l'intérieur quand il y a eu c'estes
souvenez-vous le le quand il y avait
Griveau à l'intérieur avec le la pteuse
? Ça ça pas vraiment été décrit.
Un Fenwick.
Un Fenwick, exact. Mais euh
ils sont chiés dessus hein.
Non mais oui mais mais moi j'aimerais
bien j'aimerais bien voir un Bob
Woodward par exemple en France. Ça pas
été analysé. Ça a pas été analysé. Vous
savez pourquoi ? Parce qu'il faut pas
monter la faiblesse de l'État pour une
guerre. Mais mais un Bob Woodward, il
vous fait l'administration Obama, il
vous fait l'administration Trump. Non
mais oui et oui mais il y aurait besoin
de ce livre pour comprendre et pour pour
voir réellement ce qui s'est passé.
Marc Devel.
Ouais
vous connaissez Marc Develt ?
Oui oui je connais. Oui oui oui. Mais
mais il faudrait que que les accès enfin
bref peu importe ce que je voulais dire
sur les gilets jaunes c'est ça c'est que
je me suis rendu compte de ça et je
trouve regrettable qu'on ait pas assez
parcouru la France comme on le fait à la
match habituellement. guerre, les PL de
guerre sur les les les gilets jaunes,
genre pleine tête, les mains.
Oui. Alors ça, on en a montré, on en a
montré mais oui,
on a montré mais c'est RT qui avait
commencé, ils ont été taxés de comment
on appelle ça ? Bien sûr, il y a
d'autres médias alternatifs puis il y a
aussi des médias.
Est-ce que ça vous a fait penser à des
techniques de contre-insurrection dignes
des pays les plus sous-développés qui
existent ?
Euh
non, c'était disons que
euh
c'était des PL de guerre quand même, non
? Oui oui, il y avait il y a eu des le
le LRAC, pas le LRAC, le lecoin le plus
mal le truc LBD40.
LBD ouais,
c'est une arme de guerre.
C'est moi, c'est considéré comme une
arme de guerre, sauf en France.
Oui, oui, ouais, ouais, oui. Non, mais
je je sais hein, je je je suis je suis
d'accord. Il y a eu un un
il y a eu un espèce d'acharnement et je
trouvais d'ailleurs parfois que c'était
c'était indécent de de demander à des
flics d'ailleurs qui qui gagnaient la
même chose que les autres en face.
Acharnement médiatique
quand ils ont pris une quinzaine de
connards pour être soi-disant
représentatif de ce mouvement-là qui les
ont fait passer pour des racistes, des
antisémites, des plats du front, des
demeurés, les redneck de base qui
voulaient faire passer pour des
trumpistes.
Ouais.
L'acharnement médiatique qu'il y a eu
dessus. Mais ça c'est c'est une question
de de
il y avait il y a eu réellement une
fébrilité du pouvoir. Oui, il y a eu
journalistique.
Non, je pense du pouvoir politique.
Poulevoir journalistique.
Le 4e pouvoir ça existe toujours.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. dans vos rêves
et c'est c'est ce que vous allez me dire
c'est que tous les médias sont en main
de grands groupes. Non mais je le sais
non, je vais pas vous dire ça. Je vais
vous dire pourquoi il y a une défiance
pourquoi il y a une défiance auprès de
la presse
mais pourquoi il y a des chaînes de
commerté ? Pourquoi il y a Tinkerview ?
C'est ça. Mais là c'est pas à moi de
répondre à cette question là. Moi
j'essaie d'exercerview.
Non
parce queon en avait marre de votre
profession.
On avait on avait marre de voir des
interviews où le le simple est court, le
passeport pour le slogan idéologique pur
animé par des des des militants
politiques autres que des qui se font
passer pour des journalistes. On en
avait marre
h
et puis on discutait avec des on avait
des potes avant, on avait des potes
reporters de guerre, on a des potes tout
ça, des potes scientifiques.
Tous ces gens-là ont pas nécessairement
disparu. Il y a encore moyen de faire.
Vous avez confiance dans le pays ?
Euh non, je suis très inquiet.
Je suis très inquiet parce que j'ai vu
des scènes
euh
vous me direz euh c'est c'est
quand j'ai vu Bacnord
euh bah allez le voir, c'est ça vaut le
coup. Euh
par contre, on a vu porte de client en
cours.
Ouais, mais il y a plein de Non, mais
quand j'ai vu Bacnord et apparemment
tout ce que les baqueux disent à peu
près que c'est à peu près ça et que
parfois même c'est c'est encore minimisé
par rapport à la réalité, ils attaquent
un quartier à un moment. Euh dans le
quartier, il y a des points de passage
euh pour les deals dans des immeubles où
ils font pousser tout un tas de de de
plantes et ils ont leur labo d'un côté
et donc ils ont creusé des trous dans
les murs euh de plusieurs appartements
pour pouvoir circuler et se carapater.
Euh ça je retenez bien ce point-là et
l'autre point c'est de voir la BAC
attaquée avec des pickup et les mecs
fusil à pompe à l'arrière. Bah ça ça m'a
rappelé la Syrie. Ça m'a rappelé
les deux les deux points les les trous
fait dans les murs pour les insurger. Ça
m'a rappelé Homes, ça m'a rappelé Ape
pour pouvoir changer de pièce. Le sniper
tout d'un côté tac tac tac qui voilà où
le mec passe avec son RPG et hop. Et
puis surtout la version pickup avec les
mecs à l'arrière, ça c'est vraiment tous
les toutes toutes les les guerrias du
monde ont ça aujourd'hui. Et de voir ça
dans un quartier de Marseille. OK, c'est
un film mais cette façon d'attaquer le
quartier de façon militaire, les mecs se
font tirer à la calache dessus à la fin.
Bah d'ailleurs, ça existe puisque il y a
des des baque de Marseille qui se sont
pris des tirs de Kashnikov. Voilà. Donc
on est on est dans une espèce de de de
comment de monté en puissance de choses
qui jusqu'à présent, vous savez, il y a
il y a une moi j'ai eu un grand choc
dans ma vie de journaliste. Ça a été ça
a été la
les assassinats Charlie Hebdo. Pourquoi
? Parce que au même moment à match, on
était en conférence de rédaction et eux
aussi à l'autre bout de Paris étaient en
conférence de rédaction. et on voit sur
nos portables la euh le la dépêche le
les euh les journalistes de Charlie Hebu
attaqués par de voilà et on comprend ce
qui se passe. Euh là tout à coup, je me
suis dit moi j'ai des copains qui sont
morts, je vous parlais de Crisson Rose
tout à l'heure, euh à chaque fois mes
copains qui sont morts qui ont été
blessés gravement euh sont morts loin et
jamais je j'avais entendu de
journalistes se faire abattre à la
Kalashnikov en plein Paris. Jamais.
dit là le truc il vient chez nous et
avant toutes les guerres qu'on faisait
quand on était mino dans les années 80
on entendait parler des guerres il y
avait des trucs épouvantables qui se
passaient
vous nous on était pas né hein
oui moi mais il y avait des guerres
comment il y avait des famines des trucs
atroces mais ça se passait loin
aujourd'hui il y a une sorte de
résonance
connexion avec la réalité
quo
de connexion avec la réalité
bah non surtout de résonance dans nos
sociétés euh
tout simplement il il y a un écho de de
de ces phénomènes et on peut plus
complètement être
isolé dans notre bulle et dire on va on
va intervenir et on va voilà et
aujourd'hui le fait je pense que c'est
c'est une bonne chose que la la les
interventions armées euh soient soient
terminées ou d'une certaine façon que la
la l'armée comment la l'intervention la
le départ des Américains d'Afghanistan
euh finalement conduisent à la fin de
ces guerres sans fin euh ou en tout cas
le début. Oui. Non mais on ne peut plus
avoir la rhthorique de l'Irak, on ne
peut plus avoir la rhthorique de la
Libye. Euh pour le bien de tel pays, on
décide tout à coup que le type qui était
là, que ce soit Saddam Hussein ou
Kanafi, qui nous a servi pendant 30 ans,
à qui on a autorisé de torturer ses ses
opposants, à qui on a autorisé de
massacrer les chites et de gazer les
curdes,
les autorisaient pas en tourner la tête.
Voilà, tout à coup devient le nouvel
Hitler parce que il est plus tout à fait
dans euh en phase avec ce qu'on fait.
Voilà. Et vendre ça à la population,
c'est ce qui s'est passé à chaque fois.
Et avec les journalistes qui passaient
les plats,
pas tous,
pas tous. Moi, j'ai connu des des
journalistes, j'ai connu à match des
journalistes qui étaient côté Saddam, je
pense à Jacques-Marie Bourget par
exemple qui était côté Saddam Hussein et
qui racontait lui pendant la guerre du
golf que une partie de ce qu'on
entendait en Occident était faux. Euh
d'aller sur place, c'est toujours la
question d'aller euh euh nous on a
toujours essayé justement d'avoir des
journalistes dans les deux camps. Si si
imaginez
pour ça ça me fait un peu ça me fait un
peu mal ce que vous dites parce que
c'est pas entièrement vrai ce que ce que
vous vous dites que les journalistes
sont des vendus que les rorteurs sont
des des alcola des machin c'est pas vra
résultat des courses
20 ans de guerre
oui
ça prouve bien que la presse elle a pas
fait son job le 4e pouvoir il faisait
quoi
vous parlez de l'Afghanistan ou
je parle de toutes les guerres en
général
guerre en général mais la presse n'a pas
non Le la presse c'est le 4e pouvoir,
c'est censé être not notre petit cours
d'autodéfense intellectuelle.
Mais c'est la condition de l'expression
de notre démocratie. Voilà.
Est-ce qu'on est encore en démocratie ?
Ça c'est toute la question. Mais mais je
crois pas que il faille accabler la
presse quand elle essaie de faire son
travail. C'est ça que je vous dis à peu
de mesure.
Ça s'appelle ça s'appelle une perte
collatérale.
Aujourd'hui, il y a un besoin de repère.
de
de d'avoir des des journalistes ou des
gens qui euh euh qui qui ont des des qui
ont des valeurs, qui ont voilà une
collatéral damage.
Oui, mais d'accord mais tout n'est pas
Moi, je crois pas que tout soit foutu.
Maintenant, vous m'avez demandé
l'évolution de la France.
France évolue inquiétante etourd'ise
absolue nécessaire de la part de nos
hommes politiques qui continent nos
écoles de journalistes. Est-ce qu'il y a
une prise de conscience
de nos écoles de journalistes ?
Est-ce que est-ce qu'on pompe pas sur le
marché du travail des futurs chômeurs
déjà formaté avec le même parti
idéologique que le formateur qui bosse
dans la salle de rédaction ? Est-ce que
on n'est pas en train de pondre des
petits militants journalistes ? Et si on
en arrive maintenant, c'est que les
journalistes d'il y a 20 ans ont été
formé par les mêmes qui ont reproduit et
reproduit et reproduit et maintenant on
les entend tous pleurer en short. On
n'est pas d'accord
mais c'est pas
alors oui, la presse n'est pas
totalement morte. Il reste encore des
journalistes,
il en reste des survivants.
Les les les
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
générations ? Vous
vous me laissez pas répondre.
conseil pour la je fais mon journaliste.
Ouais mais mais en fait Oui, vous vous
faites euh en fait le type qui fait fait
les questions et les réponses en même
temps. Journaliste, c'est ça. Non
non non, on est là pour poser des
questions et pour écouter les réponses.
C'est un peu intéressant de temps en
temps. Mais non, le conseil pour les
pour les jeunes malheureusement et je le
dis je le dis en à mes élèves quand je
suis devant eux et je leur explique
alors ils veulent tous essayer de de je
j'essaie de leur filer des adresses
parfois de leur filer des numéros de
boîtes de prod ou de ou de les orienter
leur dire tiens tu fais un truc sur la
peine de mort tu devrais ou sur les
prisons, tu devrais aller appeler Pierre
B, tu devrais voilà le numéro enfin tu
vois des choses comme ça. J'essaye.
Voilà. Maintenant,
dans mes rédactions,
oui,
on a on a recruté un certain nombre de
journalistes. Vous savez, il y a un
problème aussi dont souffle la
profession, c'est souvent le la
cooptation.
Et moi, je suis l'exemple inverse.
L'exemple inverse, je vous ai expliqué
au début que j'ai eu un stage. Voilà,
des dizaines de stagiaires à Mat, j'en
ai vu passer. Il y en a très très peu
qui sont restés mais bon, c'est on m'a
entrouvert la porte et j'ai eu cette
chance. Euh maintenant euh sans euh
avoir une connexion à l'intérieur, c'est
très difficile souvent. Euh alors, il y
a maintenant les l'école de journalisme
euh on on ont on renversé le problème
d'une certaine façon en offrant euh des
stages, en ayant des des rapports avec
certains médias et en offrant des stages
qui permet à un certain nombre de de
jeunes journalistes d'émerger. Euh et ça
ça peut euh euh ça peut combler
justement ce déficit et ça peut combler
le fait que euh beaucoup euh j'ai lu un
il y a hier ou avant-hier queil y a euh
il y a une étude sur les les
journalistes qui arrêtent de faire du
journalisme. Une étude là qui est qui
est sortie euh qui explique un peu comme
les chevaux qui arrêtent l'équitation.
Oui,
[Rires]
mais c'est cette espèce de reconversion
qui vient en partie pour des raisons
financières,
psychologique.
Psychologique aussi et puis
partie hein.
Et puis aussi le le une certaine
lassitude et puis
certains harcèlements dans les salles de
rédaction. Là, on a eu encore des des
journalistes qui travaillent dans un
média de gauche très connu.
Ouais. Oui. Mais c'est souvent les moins
vous savez les les cordonniers sont les
moins moins bien chaussés. meilleur en
fait les plusurs de leçon sont souvent
non c'est c'est c'est ceux qui postent
réellement
Ah oui oui. Non mais vous parlez de
médiat de gauche souvent des des
donneurs de leçons et en réalité à
droite ça donne des leçons partout hein.
Journaliste quoi. H
hein
h
on a fait le conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Vous voulez rajouter un petit mot ?
Je pense que si quelqu'un est toujours
passionné par ce métier enfin à la
passion de ce métier, il va y arriver.
Ah ouais.
Alors après, il faut se donner les
moyens. Il arrivera peut-être mort,
hein.
Non, non, non, non. Il peut y arriver.
Sacerdoce,
c'est un vrai sacerdoce. C'est un c'est
plus qu'une profession. Faut vraiment
être hanté par le truc. Il pense c'est
nuit et jours et surtout pas hésiter
malheureusement à donner sur sa vie
privée. J'ai remarqué que souvent les
jeunes, ils ont une vie à côté machin.
Nous, on avait pas de vie hein quand on
quand on a commencé. On attendait le
dimanche à la rédaction avec avec le
rédacteur en chef qui dormait
qui est que le téléphone sonne, qui a un
sujet et qu'on soit là et et que
peut-être on nous envoie. Non non,
c'était très dur. C'était très dur aussi
à l'époque de de s'imposer, de faire son
trou. C'était très dur.
Régisse le somier. Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
[Musique]